Heute ist der 29. September, also der letzte Mittwoch im Monat und das bedeutet, ihr hört Chaos Radio bei. Fritz, der Computer-Blumun mit dem Chaos Computer Club und mit Johnny am Mikrofon. Das Thema heute in dieser Sendung lautet E-Mail und Usenet beziehungsweise E-Mail und Newsgroups. Man beschweren sich hier immer so viele Leute über die Musik, deswegen haben wir gedacht wir fangen heute mal ein bisschen softer an. Das ist schon echt die schöne Sache. Mal jetzt erstmal die üblichen Mikrotests.
Tim Schnullz.
Machen wir nochmal.
Test, Nullz.
Na, klingt schon besser.
Klingt schon besser, ne? Ja, ein bisschen schnullsig, wenn wir eingestiegen heute haben.
Na, das macht nichts. Dann haben wir Florian hier.
Hallo?
Nicht scritchen.
Nicht scritchen. Die Lampe ist egal, da müssen wir sprechen. Ja, irgendwas klappert richtig fies.
Dirk, sag mal was.
Ich hänge an dein Mikro.
Genau, das Mikro muss vor den Mund.
Alles klar.
So, und das Mikro hier, das müssen wir irgendwie noch ein bisschen dichter zu euch kriegen. Und dann vielleicht so nach oben, so in Richtung Mund. Ihr müsstet mal sehen, wir sind hier in einem der modernsten Sendungsstudios Europas.
Das ist ein Kabel.
Das ist nicht das Kabel, das ist das Mikro, was an dein Bart rutscht. Nein, das ist nicht.
Das ist ein modernes Sendungsstudio Europas.
Aber das hatten wir glaub ich schon.
Doch, gibt's schon. Du hast dein Modem vergessen.
Soll ich das mal konfigurieren während der Sendung?
Ich hab mein Modem nicht vergessen.
Das ist was ganz anderes.
Wir haben aber trotzdem gerade ein enormes Problem, weil... Übrigens, wenn ihr redet während andere reden, dann hört man nichts mehr, weil alle dann reden. Nur so als Tipp. Aber irgendein Mikro raschelt tatsächlich ganz enorm und fies.
Soll ich mal...
Und jetzt müssen wir die Kabel raus schwenken oder was?
Warte mal, ich mach mal eins hin aus. Ist das jetzt weg? Dann war es Tims Mikro. Ja, dann kriegst du ein anderes Mikro. Nee, warte, da war es wieder.
Dann ist es doch meins.
Doch, deins. Was denn jetzt? Ist es deins? Warte. Na, ich muss... Was denn jetzt für Musik? Was hat ihr denn da mitgebracht? Von Beatnik kommt die Musik heute.
Genau.
Aus Hamburg.
Hamburg.
Ist das ein Club-Mitglied?
Na ja, sind wir das nicht alle irgendwie?
Na ja. Das rascheln ist jetzt weg, das heißt, Dirk braucht gleich ein neues Mikro. Machen wir gleich. Thema heute, E-Mail und Usenet und wir tauschen mal schnell das Mikro aus. Dann geht's weiter. So, jetzt probieren wir es nochmal. Jetzt Mikro noch ein bisschen dichter vor deinem Mund und dann haben wir es. Super. Wer gibt uns denn eine kleine Einführung, was wir in den nächsten drei Stunden, nein, jetzt nur noch zwei Stunden, eine dreiviertel zu hören kriegen werden? Email, kann man zum Thema Email wirklich eine Dreistundensendung machen?
Also wir haben schon festgestellt, dass wir eigentlich auch eine Sechsstundensendung draus machen könnten.
Das ist wirklich ein ziemlich unendliches Thema.
Aber wir wollen es natürlich nicht unendlich machen. Wer raschelt denn jetzt? Ihr müsst nicht so erschreckt gucken. Also ja, wir wollen uns mal ein bisschen über Email unterhalten. Und zwar halt wirklich im Email der Dienst als Seucher. Das ist ja sicherlich alles schon mal ein bisschen angesprochen worden in früheren Sendungen. Aber wir wollen gleich mal ein bisschen erzählen, wo das herkommt. Und dann vor allem, wie es funktioniert. Und zwar vor allem, um einen Überblick zu schaffen, dass man sich irgendwie eine Vorstellung davon machen kann, was eigentlich für Mechanismen angestoßen werden, bis eine E-Mail tatsächlich ankommt. Und was dabei alles so falsch gehen kann und was vielleicht der Grund all dieser sinnlosen Meldungen ist, die jeder von uns schon mal in seiner Inbox gehabt hat. Du weißt schon. Delivery, Failure Notice.
Achso, ich dachte du meintest Free Sex.
Dollar, Dollar, Make Money Fast und genau all diese Sachen. Also auch Sülze wird sozusagen ein Thema sein. Na ja, soll ich jetzt mal anfangen?
Ach, lass anfangen.
Ja, also es war einmal vor gar nicht allzu langer Zeit, da gab es das Internet in seinen frühen Zügen und da wurde halt kräftig geforscht, wie so die Computer miteinander reden könnten, online und wie man sie alle vernetzen kann, das ist ja so eine Geschichte, die wir ja schon mehrfach erzählt haben und die ja dann mittlerweile auch in den Medien auch häufiger erzählt wird, weil sie ja nun verstanden haben, dass es Internet gibt. Was weniger bekannt ist, ist, dass es damals parallel zu dem eigentlichen ARPAnet-Projekt und diesem Internet, diesem aufkanenden Internet, vor allem schon so eine Szene gab, die sich damals um das Betriebssystem Unix herum gruppiert hat, die nannte sich Usenet. Und Usenet verwendete damals halt noch nicht diese Internetprotokolle, wie man das heute im Internet macht, sondern ein ganz spezielles Programm, was es eben unter Unix gab, was eigentlich nichts anderes machte als die Möglichkeit des Dateikopierens zwischen einzelnen Unix-Computern, die mit Modems verbunden sind, zu machen. Das heißt, man sagte, ich will diese Datei auf diesen anderen Computer haben und dann ruft halt nachts irgendwie der eine Computer den anderen an und damit die Datei übertragen. Auf diesem Mechanismus. Das Ganze heißt Unix to Unix Copy. Ist also unter der Abkürzung UUCP bekannt geworden. Und mit UUCP konnte man halt relativ tolle Sachen machen, zum Beispiel die beiden Dienste, die im Newsnet groß geworden sind, ließen sich damit wunderbar übertragen. Das sind Mail und News. Und das Mail und News, wie man das heute aus dem Internet kennt, das ist eben dieses Mail und News, was sich im Newsnet entwickelt hat. Ich bin ja ganz schön am rein Blasen. Ich komme mir das nur so laut vor.
Das atmen alle sehr laut.
Wir sind ja alle noch gar nicht richtig entspannt.
Packt das Lichtschwert ein, Johnny. Ja, toll. Sind dir noch keine Fragen gekommen? Ist alles relativ plausibel bislang? Ja. Also was ist eigentlich das Bemerkenswerte? Also Mail und News waren halt, ich weiß nicht, ob die wirklich gleichzeitig entstanden sind damals. Also so in etwa schon. Mail ist halt persönliche Post und News ist halt öffentliche Post. Das ist eigentlich das, was man daraus ziehen muss.
Das schwarze Brett.
Genau, das schwarze Brett. Also während man bei Mail halt Nachrichten an Personen richtete, kann man mit News Nachrichten in einem bestimmten Kontext veröffentlichen. Und dazu gibt es halt diese hierarchisch gegliederten News-Gruppen, die sich da so entwickelt haben, kennt man ja, kommt es, es ist tralala, altsex, bizarr und was nicht alles. Jeder hat da so seine eigenen Vorlieben. Und das interessante daran eigentlich ist, das ist uns hier auch nochmal bei der Vorbesprechung so klar geworden, dass wir da eigentlich auch relativ wenig Unterschiede sehen. Leider ist es heute so, dass die Software, mit der man arbeitet, irgendwie zwischen News und Mail grob unterscheidet. Und man halt entweder Mail macht, oder man macht halt entweder News. Und es gibt eigentlich sehr, sehr wenige Softwarepakete, die das zusammenbringen. Weil eigentlich sollte man das gemeinsam benutzen. Aber da werden wir nochmal drauf eingehen im Laufe der Sendung, denke ich. Das ist eine der Aufgaben, die sozusagen in der Zukunft anstehen.
Mail ist auch für jeden Internet-Einsteiger irgendwie natürlich eins der ersten Sachen, die er benutzt. Also wir kriegen ja selber bei chaosradio.at ob.de viele Test-Mails. Heute gab es gerade wieder zwei, wo man sich denkt, habt ihr eigentlich nichts anderes zu tun? Da kommt ein Test an, super.
Das ist ja noch harmlos, aber diese ganzen Dollar, Dollar, Dollar.
Wie werde ich Hacker? Also mit Mail beschäftigt man sich doch relativ schnell, wenn man dann erstmal den Zugang zum Internet gefunden hat. Newsgroups sind komischerweise, also das Usenet ist irgendwie nicht so richtig populär. Zumindest in Deutschland nicht, was wahrscheinlich an der größtenteils Englischsprachigkeit der Newsgroups noch liegt, wobei es eine Menge auf Deutsch gibt, aber das ist doch sehr computerbezogen. Na, es gibt keine bunten Bilder.
Oh doch.
Oh, da gibt es viele bunte Bilder.
Also irgendwann hat auch mal jemand veröffentlicht, dass es auch bei News Texts gibt, und das ist natürlich der Garant dafür, dass auch dieser Dienst niemals verschwinden wird, weil eigentlich alles, mit dem man Sex über irgendwas verbreiten kann, sich lange halten wird. Aber News erschließt sich, glaube ich, den Leuten deshalb, nicht weil man schon so eine gewisse Medienkompetenz entwickelt haben muss, um damit wirklich gut umzugehen. Damals im Usenet hat sich auch die Netiquette herausgebildet. Das ist so eine Reihe von Regeln oder, sagen wir mal, Verhaltensvorschlägen, wie man denn das Netz nehmen sollte. Damals waren ja nun alle Neueinsteiger noch relativ technisch und denen war das auch schnell klar zu machen, worin sie sich da bewegten. Heutzutage ist das schon deutlich schwieriger. Die Netiquette hat solche Sachen gebracht wie überleg dir erstmal zweimal bevor du irgendwas postest und lese alles erstmal durch, bis du überhaupt weißt, womit du es zu tun hast und brüll die Leute nicht an und mach keine Flame Wars und noch ein paar andere sehr praktische Sachen. Während damals, also damals ist jetzt so Anfang der 90er Jahre, die Netiquette eigentlich wirklich auch jedem noch unter die Nase gehalten wurde und es irgendwie so Bestandteil der Kommunikation war, das auch zu wissen. Also es war so etwas, was man halt wissen musste, dass es das gibt.
Ich finde das ist ein enorm wichtiger Punkt, weil...
Ja, ja und heute ist das halt überhaupt nicht mehr so.
Also heute kommt man sich oft vor, als ob man in eine Knalpe geht und jeder erst mal losbrüllt, ohne dass man vielleicht erstmal guckt, wie viele Leute sind da oder vielleicht mal hallo in die Runde wirft oder so eine Geschichte. Und ja, das ist eigentlich schade, weil... Da geht es Deutschland online, aber leider wissen die meisten nicht, wie.
Ja, ich denke, was damals halt noch klar war, war, dass man eben einen gemeinschaftlichen Raum sich teilt. Das war halt damals noch klar. Und heute ist halt mit diesen tausenden Websites, tausenden Chat-Roms, tausenden Hass nicht gesehen, sehen die Leute halt das Internet mehr so als Straßennetz im Allgemeinen an. Und dann wird halt hier mal irgendwie ordentlich Gummi gegeben und da hinten werden die Omas überfahren. Also das ist wie im richtigen Leben. Das muss man glaube ich auch akzeptieren und wird sich auch nicht sehr viel daran ändern können. Aber wenn man halt bewusst mit Mellow News umgehen will, dann lohnt sich das sehr, sich da reinzufuchsen. Insbesondere, weil News ein sehr einfacher Weg ist, an Informationen ranzukommen, die man anderswo nicht so ohne weiteres bekommen würde. Also man stellt da eine Frage und siehe da, innerhalb von ein, zwei Tagen kriegt man auch eine Antwort, weil halt alle Leute, die sich für ein bestimmtes Thema interessieren, da mitlesen.
Na ja.
Kann man vielleicht nachher noch ein bisschen genauer erklären, wie Newsgroups, wie das Usenet genau funktioniert, nicht nur technisch, sondern auch inhaltlich, was da genau abgeht, vielleicht auch, wie man da rankommt für die Leute, die es... Also ich hab's schon öfter erlebt, dass sie gesagt hat, findest du in der Newsgroup so und so und wenn man das einfach im Browser eingibt, dann funktioniert das natürlich nicht. Wobei es inzwischen auch browserbasierte Newsreader gibt und so weiter, aber das kann man vielleicht nachher alles nochmal auswälzen, weil gleich gibt's nämlich erstmal eine kurze Info. Ich glaub, so ein anderes von dem, über was wir alles reden werden, haben wir schon gemacht, wird natürlich beim Thema E-Mail, wenn wir sicher auch aufs Thema Technik zu sprechen kommen, wie geht das alles überhaupt zum Thema...
Weil das ja auch Sachen sind, die einem permanent über den Weg kommen.
Richtig, Mail benutzen die Leute, die das Internet regelmäßig benutzen, sicher mehrfach täglich und na gut, Newsgroups dann auch, aber Telnet benutzt man vielleicht nicht mehr so oft.
Ich fang jetzt wieder damit an.
Wir werden über Spam reden, wir werden über Mailinglisten reden, vielleicht auch über Sicherheit.
Genau, dann werden wir uns noch ein paar Sätze einfallen lassen, die man so einfach im Radio fallen lassen kann, dass der Nachrichtmann kommt und weiß, woher ich bin.
Oder wir wöcheln jetzt mal alle fünf ins Mikrofon, ganz laut. Dann können wir die Zeit dann schon überbrücken. Chaosradio, Ausgabe 43. Chaosgabe 43, heute zum Thema E-Mail und Usenet. Auf Ich hab jetzt grad natürlich wieder den richtigen Jingle nicht zur Hand. Deswegen, wenn Fritz im Internet, dann www.fritz.de. Hm, und warum gehen die Jingles auch nicht, die hier? Ach so, weil ich sie jetzt nicht mehr habe. Das ist natürlich extrem blöder, weil ich meine, das Kette weggegeben hab. Super, warte mal, du musst so kurz, Falk, kannst du eine Geschichte aus deinem Leben erzählen?
Eine wirklich interessante und ein Schwank.
Zum Beispiel, was ist deine älteste Kindheitserinnerung?
Oh je, so ad hoc.
Nee, sag mal, was ist deine Liebssüßigkeit?
Meine Lieblingssüßigkeit? Ähm, ich hab Snickers esse ich zum Beispiel sehr gerne. Immer wieder so, gerne, wie jetzt in der Regel, oder?
Unsere Nachrichtensprecher werden ausgestattet von Swishara.
Stellungnahme, der SPD-Landesvorstand in Brandenburg hat sich am Abend für den Koalitionsvertrag mit der CDU ausgesprochen. Dem SPD-Sonderparteitag am 4. Oktober wurde die Bildung einer großen Koalition empfohlen. Aufschub, die Bundesregierung hat heute ihren Beschluss vertagt, 100 deutsche Sanitätssoldaten nach Osttimor zu schicken. Zum einen ist die Truppenentsendung in der Koalition umstritten, zum anderen ist die Finanzierung noch unklar. Konflikt, ein Einmarsch russischer Truppen in Tschechien wird immer wahrscheinlicher. Nach einer Woche massiver Bombenangriffe auf Tschechien ist ein erster Gesprächsversuch der russischen Regierung mit der Führung der abtrünnigen Kaukasusrepublik gescheitert. Westliche Regierungen äußerten sich besorgt über die Eskalation. Altlast. In Oranienburg ist heute erneut eine Bombe aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg entschärft worden. Seit 1990 war es der 69. Einsatz eines Sprengkommandos in dem Ort. Fußball. In der Champions League steht das Kurzvorschluss wie folgt. Borussia Dortmund gegen Rosenborg Trondheim 2 zu 2 und Leverkusen gegen Kiew 1 zu 1.
Wette.
Nachts zeitweise Regen um 12 Grad, morgen bewölkt gelegentlich Regen. Tageshöchsttemperaturen 17 bis 20 Grad.
Verkehr.
Verkehrsmeldungen liegen uns zurzeit nicht vor. Gucken sowieso alle Fußball. Fritz wünscht gute Fahrt.
Heute ist Fußball? Das war ein nicht aus der Ruhe zu bringender Feigstilke mit dem Fritz-Kurzinfo.
Das erste Europa-Liga-Heimspiel der neuen Saison. Donnerstag, 30. September um 20 Uhr in der Mark-Schmähling-Halle.
Alba Berlin gegen Olympia Ljubljana.
Und das Motto lautet wie immer, wenn Alba dann tritt.
Genau, das hört ihr hier bei Fritz Chaosradio. Jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat mehr Infos unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Das Ganze im www. Unsere E-Mail-Adresse ist chaosradio.at.op.de.
Seit wann das eigentlich?
Ist doch chaos.at.op.de.
Eigentlich ist es nämlich chaos.at.op.de, aber auf euren neuen...
Verdammt.
Auf der neuen Homepage von Fritz steht jetzt chaosradio.at.op.de. Ich hab da auch schon mal was hingemeldet, aber ich hab das mindestens nicht gekriegt. Vielleicht sollten wir doch mal chaosradio.ccc.de einrichten. Ich glaub, das ist zuverlässiger. Weil das ist nämlich immer so eine Sache mit der Zuverlässigkeit von Mail-Konfigurationen.
Da sind wir auch schon wieder richtig mittendrin im Thema. Zum Thema Mail-Zwerber konfigurieren hab ich in den letzten Wochen auch einiges gelernt. Man will ja dann doch immer mehr machen, ne? Irgendwann muss man ja dann so bestimmte Sachen selber machen und es geht und dann baut man Scheiße und dann kriegt man drei Tage lang keine Mails und auch tot.
Redest du jetzt wieder von Wörth-Virus?
Nee, davon nicht, um Gottes Willen. Aber wir können mal ein bisschen anfangen, wie Mail überhaupt funktioniert. Was passiert da, wenn man einen Text eintippt in sein Mailprogramm? Warum brauch ich überhaupt ein spezielles Mail?
Weil du eigentlich für jeden Dienst ein spezielles Programm brauchst.
Ja, frag mich sowieso, warum ich immer verschiedene Programme brauche. Warum kann mein Computer nicht alles automatisch?
Nimm doch Netscape.
Naja, gut, Netscape hat ja mit seinem Navigator, Kommunikator im Prinzip versucht, genau das zu machen. So irgendwie Mail, News, Web, alles in allem. Genau, alles nicht richtig. Das ist halt das Problem. Eigentlich, wenn man richtig schön ordentlich damit arbeiten will, dann will man irgendwie Programme mit Features und man kann von einem einzelnen Programm das einfach nicht erwarten. Naja, aber du fragtest ja, wie das so funktioniert. Ich hatte ja völlig schon ausgeführt, dass das Ganze aus dem Usenet kam und da gab es halt das nicht, was es heute gibt. Nämlich, dass alle Rechner miteinander im Brief virtuell verbunden sind. Und Post von einem Rechner zu einem anderen zu bekommen über ein Netz von Computern, wo nur manche sich manchmal einmal am Tag oder in der Nacht per Modem irgendwelche Dateien hin und her schicken, das war natürlich schwierig. Man wollte halt irgendwie eine Mail schicken, ein Rechner XY, aber der hängt halt nicht an dem eigenen dran, sondern man hat selber vielleicht einen Rechner angerufen in der eigenen Stadt und der stand in Verbindung mit einem Rechner in einer ganz anderen Stadt, der dann wiederum mit noch einem in Verbindung steht, der dann vielleicht mit dem in Verbindung steht, wo die Mail eigentlich hin soll. Und dann hat man sich große Dateien zusammengetragen, sogenannte Maps, in denen genau das drin stand. Welcher Rechner ruft welchen Rechner wie häufig an? Und dann gab es wiederum andere Klugeprogramme, die das einmal durchgegangen sind und dann so gesehen haben, aha, wenn ich also eine Mail da hinschicken will, dann ist der kürzeste Weg der. Und dann hab ich eine Mail geschrieben, und dann wurde das umgerechnet in einen Pfad. Der schrieb sich dann so mit Ausrufezeichen dazwischen, deswegen sind die Dinger auch als Bank Passes bekannt geworden. Das heißt, das war dann eine ganze Latte von Rechnern, wo es halt von Rechner zu Rechner zu Rechnern ging. Das war natürlich auch nicht besonders schnell, weil es dauerte halt noch echt viele Tage, bis die Mail auch ankam.
Und die Maps, wo es mussten verteilt werden?
Und die Maps mussten vor allem auf allen Systemen gleich sein und immer aktualisiert sein und richtig sein. Und es gab sozusagen einige Probleme. Aber trotzdem hat sich dieses Prinzip des sogenannten Store and Forward halt durchgesetzt. Das heißt, eine Mail wird auch heute noch im Prinzip so behandelt. Ich schicke sie halt erstmal los. Dazu schicke ich sie an einen ersten Rechner. Und dann wird sie so lange an andere Rechner weitergeleitet, bis sie halt da ist, wo sie hingehört. Heutzutage sollte dieser Weg natürlich möglichst kurz sein. Aber wir werden gleich nochmal ausfinden, dass da so oder so immer mehrere Rechner mit beschäftigt sind. Bei News funktioniert das anders.
Du warst der Experte für News?
Ich bin der Experte für News.
Du ist unser.
Wofür seid ihr beide eigentlich Experten? Vielleicht ist ja draußen News-Explosion, der kann uns dann mal anrufen.
Bei News ist halt da ein anderes Verteilungsschema. Da gibt es halt diese News-Groups. Und man postet seine Nachricht halt an einen News-Server, der im Prinzip in Massen halt diese Nachrichten sammelt und an anderen News-Server weiterweicht. Und die tauschen sich halt die ganze Zeit untereinander aus. Welche Nachricht hast du noch nicht? Dann schicke ich dir die mal, weil ich hab die. So, und nach diesem Schema werden halt diese Nachrichten an jeden weitergeleitet. Das heißt, in News ist das Interessante, dass eine Nachricht halt überall ist. Wenn man also, falls ihr irgendwie gleich von der Mafia umgebracht werdet, falls es also droht und ihr müsst also unbedingt der Welt noch eine Nachricht geben und ihr wollt irgendwie möglichst dafür sorgen, dass diese Nachricht auf Ewigkeiten erhalten bleibt und auf jeden Fall gefunden werden kann, dann ist es der beste Weg, das im Internet News zu posten, weil dann ist es innerhalb von wenigen Minuten auf echt verdammt vielen Computern.
Dann muss man schnell nur noch Rec.Mafia.
Man sollte schon eine Newsgruppe nehmen, die es gibt.
Also ich mein, auch Mail wird ja auf einem Server gelagert, bis man sie abholt. Der Unterschied ist einfach, dass bei einem Mail-Server, ich, sobald ich mich mit dem Internet verbinde, jetzt mit einer Einwählverbindung, gehe ich hin und hole meine Post ab, sozusagen auf meinen Rechner bei mir zu Hause. Da habe ich halt einen Account und ein Passwort, damit da erstmal niemand ran kann. Und beim News-Server können halt alle ran. Also sobald man den richtig eingegeben hat und ein Provider einen News-Server zur Verfügung stellt oder es ist ein ganz öffentlicher News-Server, können eigentlich alle mitlesen und wie aus dem schwarzen Brett die Nachrichten untereinander eigentlich abrufen, darauf antworten. Auch die Antworten kann dann wieder jeder sehen, außer man verschickt sie per Mail.
Genau, also 1000 Kombinationen sind möglich. Aber vielleicht sollten wir einfach mal erläutern, wie das eigentlich ist mit der Mail. Wenn du deine Mail-Konfiguration, man kennt das ja sicherlich, Netscape starten, dann fragt er dich erstmal tausend sinnlose Sachen, von denen du noch nie irgendwas gehört hast. Und gerade bei E-Mail muss man echt viel eingeben. Da gibt es dann einen Mail-Server. Manche bezeichnen das. Ja genau, da fängst du nämlich schon wieder an. Es gibt nämlich eigentlich so etwas wie einen Mail-Server eigentlich nicht, weil es gibt verschiedenste Protokolle, die eine Rolle spielen. Na ja, vielleicht sollte man einfach mal am Anfang anfangen. Also du schreibst halt deine Mail und das tust du mit einem sogenannten MUA.
Mit einem Mail User Agent. Genau.
Und was macht der Mail User Agent?
Der Mail User Agent nimmt diese Post entgegen und sorgt dafür, dass sie über einen Mail Transport Agent, wie zum Beispiel Sendmail, ausgeliefert wird. Genau.
Vielleicht sollten wir noch was zu der Mail selbst sagen. Die besteht nämlich aus mehreren Teilen, aus dem Header und aus dem Buddy. Und im Header stehen so Zusatzinformationen oder Meta-Informationen. Und im Buddy steht der eigentliche Text, den man verschicken will. Aber im Header steht halt auch an wen es gehen soll, von wem es kommt.
Und andere unwichtige Informationen, die dein Mail User Agent da noch reinschreibt.
Genau.
Im Header steht dann zum Beispiel, wie heute, wo ich eine Mail bekommen hab, von der er geschrieben hat, du findest nie raus, wer ich bin. So ein Fritz Hörer oder so. Und im Header steht dann drin Telefonnummer, AT-Online-DE. Also man kann manchmal aus dem Header wirklich lustige Sachen rauslesen, aber auch nicht besonders oft. Was manchmal helfen kann, wenn irgendwas nicht funktioniert, wenn man eine Ahnung davon hat, kann man ein bisschen rausfinden, wo es vielleicht...
Genau, das ist nämlich überhaupt sehr interessant. Also wenn man eine Mail bekommt, sollte man sich ruhig mal die Zeit nehmen und sich mal den Header durchlesen. Das hängt dann wiederum sehr von dem Mailprogramm ab, was man verwendet, wie gut es das einem anzeigt. Aber eigentlich sollten alle Mailer, die die Funktion haben, einen vollständigen Header anzuzeigen. Das sieht dann erst mal ziemlich kryptisch aus, da sind 1000 Zeichen drin. Und immer so zeilen nach dem Schema Keyword, also ein Name, ein Doppelpunkt und eine restliche Information. Zum Beispiel tour.johnny.orb.de oder et fritz.de Das wäre dann erstmal wo es hingeht. Und dann steht noch drin from.tim.ccc.de Und dann kommen aber noch weitere Sachen drin. Was zum Beispiel ganz interessant ist, sind die Wege, die das langgeht.
Das ist das, was wir hier bei, daran kann man feststellen, woher diese Mail etwa kommen. Also man sieht den Weg der Rechner, über die sie gelaufen ist und auch die Zeit, an der diese Mail an jedem Rechner angekommen ist.
Sieht man den gesamten Weg immer?
Man sieht den gesamten Weg bis zum Absender.
Kann es sein, dass die kürzer geworden sind? Also weil, ey, kann ich mich dran erinnern, dass früher waren da teilweise endlose Geschichten, also dass die Mail wirklich von Rechner zu Rechner zu Rechner rund um die Welt.
Das ist halt das, was ich vorhin meinte. Früher war halt viel noch... Was für ein früher meinst du jetzt?
So 92.
Das war eben dieses Door-in-Forward, das heißt es ging über sehr viele Rechner, weil die Rechner nicht miteinander vernetzt waren. Jetzt ist es eben so, der Absenderrechner versucht, möglichst direkt Kontakt mit dem für die jeweilige Domäne zuständigen Rechner aufzunehmen. Insofern wird natürlich auch der Weg kürzer.
Tja, wollen wir da jetzt noch genauer einsteigen? Ja, genau. Das mit dem Boot, den du jetzt hier von A nach B kommt.
Ja, das mit dem SMTP. Ich denke, das ist nämlich irgendwie erklärungsbedürftig. Also was ist ein SMTP-Server?
Warte mal, ganz kurz. MUA, also Mail User Agent, das ist eigentlich mein Mail-Programm.
Genau.
Klar ist E-Mailer, Outlook, Netscape, was auch immer. Also das, womit man die Mail schreibt und womit man sagt Send. Und da, wo man sie liest, das ist der User Agent, wie der Name schon sagt. Also derjenige, der tatsächlich Kontakt mit der Realität aufnimmt.
Da fällt mir übrigens gerade noch was Wichtiges ein. Habt ihr irgendwo, reden wir auch darüber, wie Mails geschrieben werden? Also weil es gibt ja seit noch nicht allzu langer Zeit diese Unart, Mails in HTML zu schreiben. Da können wir vielleicht nachher nochmal einen Satz zu sagen, dass vielleicht alle ihren Outlook umkonfigurieren.
Auch noch zu den Gefahren von HTML-Mail. Also das ist nicht nur ärgerlich, sondern kann manchmal auch für den Empfänger echt...
So, das heißt, der erste Schritt ist, ich schreib die Mail, dann drücke ich auf Send und dann passiert Folgendes. Der Mail User Agent, das Programm, nimmt Kontakt auf mit dem Computer, den du eingetragen hast, als, wie das dann auch immer heißt, SMTP Server oder Mail Server. Das ist eben ein Computer, auf dem ein Mail Transfer Agent, also ein Programm zum Weiterleiten von Mail, installiert ist. Und der nimmt die Mail per SMTP an.
Vorausgesetzt, sie wird nicht lokal, also wenn du von einem Unix-Rechner aus deine Mail verschickst, dann wird die lokal dem SMTP Server übergeben. Also nicht über SMTP, aber der schickt sie dann per SMTP, was Simple Mail Transfer Protocol heißt, an, ja genau, an wen eigentlich.
Und hier sind wir schon. Eine Adresse setzt sich ja aus Benutzername und Domain zusammen. Und hier ist es natürlich so, für ein Domain gibt es sogenannte Mail Exchanger. Das sind Rechner, die sich verantwortlich fühlen für diese Domain, also Post für sie entgegennehmen und auch wissen, wo sich der Benutzer befindet und diese dem weiterleiten. Das heißt, der Mail Transfer Agent stellt fest, zu welchem Rechner muss ich dieses Mail routen und versucht sie dort direkt per SMTP abzugeben.
Das muss doch auch wie damals dann funktionieren, dass diese Dateien sozusagen, also die Information, wo steht der Rechner, rüsselmösel.de, das muss doch auch ständig geupdatet werden, oder?
Das wird jetzt anders gemacht. Also früher musste man halt den Weg wissen, um den schon in die richtige Richtung loszuschicken. So wie früher, wenn man im Wald irgendwie Booten durch die Gegend geschickt hat, um die andere Bande zu erreichen.
Und heute?
Heute sind sie ja im Prinzip alle miteinander verbunden.
Heute nimmt man das für den Domain Name Service, also für den DNS-Dienst, und da stehen die MX-Einträge drin.
Also da, wo auch die IP-Einträge stehen.
Und da gibt es dann unter Umständen mehrere MX-Records, was Mail-Exchanger heißt, ich weiß nicht, ob wir das schon erklärt haben. Und diese Server fühlen sich zuständig, die sind priorisiert. Also jeder dieser Rechner hat eine Preference. Und je niedriger die Preference ist, desto besser ist der geeignet, um die Mail dem zu geben, der sie haben soll. Und jeder SMTP-Server guckt erst mal nach, was ist der niedrigste MX-Rekord? Und versucht dann die Mail dahin zu schicken, wenn das gerade nicht geht, dann nimmt er den nächstes höher präferiert. Also was heißt höher, niedriger, naja. Das ist halt irgendwie genau andersrum.
Wir können ja mal ein Beispiel machen. Also bleiben wir doch mal irgendwie, ich schick dir eine Mail. Also tim.lccc.de, ich schreib halt jetzt eine Mail, dann drück ich irgendwie auf send. Und mein Programm überträgt das an den SMTP-Server, an den Mail-Transfer-Agent, den ich eingestellt habe. Das ist dann halt mail.ccc.de. Ein Computer, der sozusagen darauf wartet, Mail von mir entgegenzunehmen, um sie dann weiterzuleiten. Der kriegt dann die Mail von mir und da steht drin to johnny-edfritz.de. Jetzt macht er Folgendes, jetzt guckt er sich das fritz.de an und fragt über DNS, also da wo man auch die IP-Adressen herbekommt, fragt er halt, welcher Computer ist zuständig, um Mail anzunehmen für alles edfritz.de.
Und das ist besagter MX-Record. Und dann versucht er mit der niedrigsten Ziffer, mit der niedrigsten Ziffer...
Mach's einfach.
Dann versucht sie dahin zu schicken.
Nehmen wir da erstmal den Idealfall an. Dieser Computer wird halt gesagt, ok, es gibt mail.fritz.de, weiß ich jetzt nicht, heißt bestimmt anders, vielleicht heißt er auch so. So und dann schickt eben mein Mail-Host an den Computer die Mail weiter mit dem Auftrag, hier leite das mal an Johnny. Ja und dann nimmt der Computer das an.
Und wartet darauf, dass ich es abhole.
Stellt fest, aha fritz.de, das brauche ich gar nicht weiterleiten, das ist hier. Und dann hängt es davon ab, wie das Netz dahinter aussieht, wohin dann die Mail konkret gemacht wird. Am besten Fall wird sie auf einem Server bereitgestellt zur Abholung und dann kommst du halt wieder mit deinem Mail-Programm und benutzt ein anderes Protokoll, um diese Mail abzuholen.
Und das ist unter Umständen POP3 oder eMAP4. Und naja, das macht dein Mail-Client halt, der holt da die Mail ab und zeigt sie dir.
Die meisten Clients sind POP-Clients, oder? Wo kommt eMAP4 her?
eMAP4 ist sozusagen eine bessere Implementation als POP, weil bei POP die Mails auf den lokalen Rechnungen kopiert werden. Wenn sie bei eMAP4 sozusagen auf dem Server liegen bleiben und von verschiedenen Workstations erreichbar sind. Das heißt, man hat immer sein Mailfolder vorrätig in der Gesamtform.
Das heißt, die Mail kommt dann nicht, wird nicht getragen, sondern nur der Inhalt dargestellt. Also ähnlich wie Dwytelnet. Wird nur auf meinem Screen sozusagen.
Also bei POP bist du gezwungen, die Mails komplett zu übertragen, während du bei eMAP, was ein neueres, moderneres Protokoll ist, was sich jetzt erst langsam anfängt durchzusetzen, du die Möglichkeit hast, einfach schon mal dir eine Liste nur aller Betreffzeilen anzeigen zu lassen. Und dann kannst du in dem Moment auswählen, ah, mich interessiert überhaupt nur die, die, die Mail. Stell dir mal vor, du bist irgendwie zwei Wochen weg und dann kriegst du irgendwie 200 Mails. Das dauert erst mal eine halbe Stunde, bevor du überhaupt anfangen kannst. Bei eMAP wäre es eben möglich zu sehen, ah, 200 Mails, du kriegst relativ schnell den Überblick und sagst, okay, das, das, das interessiert mich jetzt und musst den anderen Müll nicht erst übertragen, bevor du ihn dir angucken kannst.
Ach, das ist ja praktisch. Das muss ich mir aber merken.
Das könnt ihr ja mal euren Sysadmin erzählen.
Der Nachteil ist natürlich...
Aber das machen auch relativ viele Provider eMAP-Services, oder?
Na ja, eigentlich nicht, denn das Problem ist natürlich, dass die Platte wird voll. Das ist relativ female, die da zu laufen hat. Und zum anderen ist eMAP in den momentan verfügbaren Implementationen ein eklatantes Sicherheitsproblem.
Das wäre meine nächste Frage gewesen, wenn die Sachen da weiter rumliegen, dann heißt das natürlich auch, wenn ich mit einem Pubclient meine Mail abhole vom Server und eingestellt habe, dass er sie dann auf dem Server löschen soll, dann ist sie bei mir. Dann ist das mein Sicherheitsproblem, ob da jemand drin rumwöhnen kann. Zumindest nachdem ich sie gelöscht habe. Vorher liegt sie natürlich auch darum auf dem Server.
Genau von daher ist der Unterschied eigentlich nicht wirklich da. Die Meldung bei eMAP ist halt nur länger da. Für die Provider heutzutage eher ein Plattenproblem. Und für die Security, da muss man sowieso sagen, auf diesem gesamten Weg, den wir da beschrieben haben, der unter Umständen sehr viele Computer, die einem nicht gehören, beteiligt sind, liegt die Mail immer im Klartext rum und kann im Prinzip beliebig vergessen, gelöscht, kopiert, modifiziert, sonst irgendwas werden, ohne dass der Empfänger eine Möglichkeit hätte, das festzustellen, dass dem so ist.
Das habe ich nie richtig verstanden, warum das so einfach ist. Also wenn ich jetzt, nehmen wir mal an, ich betreibe einen der Rechner, die so sozusagen, wo irgendwelche Mails von irgendjemand an irgendjemanden auf Durchreise sind. Dann sind die ja aussen sichtlich nur Bruchteile von Sekunden da, oder?
Naja, das ist grundsätzlich mal eine Konfigurationsfrage. Natürlich sind die Rechner bemüht, die Mail möglichst schnell auszuliefern. Man will ja die Post möglichst bald erhalten. Es ist aber so, dass ich natürlich sagen kann, ich möchte diese Mail vorhalten oder ich möchte sie zum Beispiel verändern. Diese Mail ist ja mit Standards beschrieben. Das heißt, es gibt einen ganz klaren Satz, wie eine Mail aufgebaut ist. Und ich kann natürlich nach bestimmten Schlüsselwörtern, zum Beispiel der Absenderzeile sehen. Und wenn ich da meinen gesuchten Absender finde, zum Beispiel Johnny, dann kann ich einfach mal alle diese Mails an mich kopieren und sie trotzdem weiterleiten oder sie verschlucken oder sie verändern.
Sind diese Zwischenstationen auch Mail-Server auf den verschiedenen Maschinen? Zum Beispiel auf den verschiedenen UNIX-Maschinen?
Das sind Mail-Server. Das ist in diesem Fall der MTA, der die Mail vom SMTP-Server des Absenders entgegengenommen hat.
Also angenommen, wir wollten irgendwie alle Mails haben, die hier bei Fritz eingehen sollen. Angenommen, es würde uns gelingen, auf dem Internet irgendwie die Nachricht zu verbreiten, dass wir mit unserem Computer, der heißt irgendwie hijack.ccc.de, so und wir würden halt sagen hijack.ccc.de ist zuständig für die Mail für fritz.de. So angenommen, uns würde gelingen das zu tun.
Dazu müsstest du aber den DNS-Eintrag erinnern, oder?
Dazu müsste ich den, hey, guter Hacker drin. Ja genau das. Also angenommen, es würde uns gelingen, diesen MX-Rekord so zu erinnern, dass hijack.ccc.de zuständig ist, dann würden alle Computer auf dieser Welt die Mail erstmal an uns schicken. Und wir könnten halt da angucken, wie du schon sagst, irgendwie Kopieren wegschmeißen, durch den Fleischwolf drehen, unterschiedliche Mails anderen Leuten zustellen, einfach die Adressaten miteinander vertauschen, sodass irgendwie der Geschäftsführer das liest, was die Sekretärin eigentlich bekommen sollte und umgekehrt. Und dann leiten wir es einfach an den eigentlichen, wirklich zuständigen Server weiter. Und ja, keiner hat was gemerkt. Die merken nichts. Man kann das natürlich feststellen, aber es würde auf jeden Fall erstmal so laufen und niemand wird es auffallen.
Gut, dabei nehmen wir mal an, du fängst nicht an, also DNS-Eintrag zu verändern, ist ja auch nicht so leicht.
Naja, nach den derzeitigen Bind-Implementierungen, die so verwendet werden.
Der Vordergrund hat ja doch eine Wiese auf, was natürlich viel einfacher ist, grundsätzlich mal dafür zu sorgen, dass ich auf der Strecke zwischen dem Absender SMTP-Server und dem Host für Fritz bin. Das heißt, ich kann zum Beispiel, wenn Fritz keine Ahnung über Snafu angebunden ist, kann der Betreiber von Snafu sämtlichen Verkehr über diese Leitung nicht mitlesen. Und natürlich auch den spezifizierten Punkt 25 für SMTP komplett mitlesen und protokollieren.
Oder auch on the fly verändern und so weiter.
Tausche das Wort Urlaub gegen Drogen aus. Zum Beispiel.
Ich hab schon wieder Drogen.
Ich brauch dringend mal wieder Drogen.
Ja, so ist das, was ich abends so mache.
Also mit anderen Worten, E-Mail ist unsicher bis ins Mark. Es gibt da genau keinen Sicherheitsmechanismus. Das Schlimmste ist vor allem, dass wenn man Pop macht, also das Schlimmste an diesem Pop, dass das Passwort, das man eingibt, an den Server unverschlüsselt übertragen wird. Das heißt, man kann auch wunderbar, wenn man irgendwo in der Leitung dazwischen hängt, wenn man irgendwo beim Provider mal auf so einem Ethernet lauscht, dann sieht man bestimmt pro Tag an die 20.000 verschiedene Passwörter rumfliegen. Man weiß auch sofort zu wem sie gehören. Und diese Information, man kann natürlich jetzt keinen Provider unterstellen. Dass er das tut, das wollen wir damit auch nicht tun. Aber möglich wäre es ohne Probleme.
Naja, es geht ja gar nicht so sehr um die Provider. Es geht um die technische Möglichkeit. Und dass wenn zum Beispiel irgendjemand in irgendwelchen Etagen beschließt, dass er jetzt den Providern... They, ich meine sie. Genau, beschließt, dass man den Providern die Auflage macht, ohne dass vielleicht eine große Glocke zu hängen. Wenn ihr in Zukunft hier Internet providen wollt, dann möchten wir gerne von euch, dass nach folgenden Stichwörtern gesucht wird oder so.
Genau das passiert.
Das wird ja die Möglichkeit.
Das wird auch getan. Also das ist die Realität.
Da gibt es so ein Gesetz.
Das klingeln die immer bei mir.
Früher haben sich immer so viele Leute gewundert, warum so viele Mailwege immer durch Virginia gehen in den USA. Also fast jede Verbindung, die man da irgendwie in frühen Zeiten gemacht hat, ging irgendwie über Virginia, bis einmal klar wird, dass da irgendwie die NSA ihre Zentrale hat.
Es gibt deswegen zum Beispiel Leute, die, wenn sie mit bestimmten Wörtern in einer Mail arbeiten, zum Beispiel auch das Stichwort Drogen, irgendwie kann ja in komplett harmlosen Zusammenhängen stehen oder von den Experten, die sich unterhalten oder so. Also wenn da dann was rausgefiltert wird, allein an Stichwörtern, das ist natürlich eine extrem heikle Geschichte. Aber es gibt deswegen Leute, die dann zum Beispiel Sternchen zwischen die Buchstaben setzen bei bestimmten Wörtern oder so ein Kram. Das ist natürlich ziemlich umständlich einfacher. Das ist natürlich sehr viel einfacher und sehr viel sicherer, dann den Kram gleich richtig zu verschlüsseln. Da hatten wir auch schon diverse Extrasendungen drüber zum Thema PGP. Da kann ja jeder selber mal gucken.
Genau, Mail ist unsicher. Und man sollte halt echt aufpassen, was man irgendwie per Mail wirklich kommuniziert. Es gab da ja ein paar schön populäre Fälle, wie Hotmail, dieser webbasierte E-Mail-Service, den Microsoft gekauft hat. Für wie viele Millionen? Für unglaublich viel Geld wahrscheinlich. Und es lohnt sich wahrscheinlich sogar auch noch für sie. Die mieten halt jedem kostenlos E-Mail an. Und das wurde dann irgendwie gehackt neulich. Man hat da so einen Weg gefunden, wie man irgendwie in die Mailboxen kommen kann.
Ich war an dem Tag nicht da und hab am nächsten Tag meine Mail gekriegt. Da war dreimal diese Meldung drin.
Das wär lustig geworden.
Weißt jemand, wie der Hack gelaufen ist bei Hotmail?
Kram. Kram, wir können ja kurz mal... Web-basierte E-Mail-Angebote sind dann... Funktioniert im Browser. Man gibt eine WWW-Adresse ein, zum Beispiel. Dann einer der bekanntesten ist eben Hotmail. Da kann sich jeder sein kostenloses Internetkonto, sein Mailkonto einrichten. Der Vorteil, der ganz am Anfang von diesen Diensten immer rausgestellt wurde, war halt der, dass man selbst wenn man seinen eigenen Computer nicht dabei hat, wenn man unterwegs ist, man kann dann an irgendeinen Rechner gehen, der einen Browser hat und kann seine Mail abfragen. Das ist auch sehr praktisch.
DMX ist auch noch so ein bekannter.
DMX ist ganz verbreitet inzwischen in Deutschland. Es gibt aber noch, weiß ich nicht, dutzende andere. Und dieser Service ist vor anderthalb Wochen oder so, oder vor zwei Wochen gehackt worden. Hotmail hat so einen Typ, dessen Name jetzt nicht einfällt, erfunden. Und dann für, weiß ich nicht, wie viele Millionen, ich kann es echt nicht fassen, ich glaube 30 Millionen oder so was an Microsoft verkauft.
War es den hack?
Oder waren es mehr? Nein, nicht den hack, sondern den Service erst mal. Gehackt worden ist, weiß ich nicht.
Das Service ist ja von einer US-Firma entwickelt worden. Das ist auch das Schöne, die hatten damals natürlich nicht Microsoft im Rücken und haben das Ganze deshalb auf BSD entwickelt. Das sind die einzigen BSD-Server bei Microsoft. Und es sind aber die, denen sie vertrauen und die viel Leistung bringen müssen.
Das Ding, was man kurz dazu sagen muss, ist ein...
Unix-Deribat.
Genau.
Ja, wie der hack genau gelaufen ist, das erzähl ich doch, ich weiß es.
Du weißt es, dann erzähl doch mal.
Also es gab da ein Skript, ich weiß den Namen nicht mehr. Jedenfalls gab es ein Skript bei Hotmail, was irgendwie das Anmelden mittels der Übergabe des Usernahmes ermöglichte. Dieses Skript ist halt irgendwie bekannt geworden, irgendjemand hat es gehört, wie auch immer. Dann gab es, um dieses Skript zu benutzen, gab es ein Interface, ein HTML-Interface, da konnte man, also eine HTML-Seite, die dann letztendlich dieses Skript aufgerufen hat, oder man hat dann dieses Skript aufgerufen. Und da konnte man einfach den Namen eintragen und dann hat man die Mailbox gesehen von demjenigen und konnte bis auf Passwortänderung, glaube ich, alles machen. Also für die Passwortänderung behaupte man halt das Passwort, deshalb war das nicht möglich, aber man konnte halt Mail zu lesen, Mail zu verschicken und das Ganze 24 Stunden lang und da sind auch irgendwie Geschichten hochgekommen von späten Leuten, Businessleuten, die dann noch in der Hotmail ihre prostituierten Kommunikationen abgewickelt haben.
Und ist halt wie mit dem E-Map-Server, die ganze Mail liegt da halt rum und man kann halt irgendwie auf alles zugreifen. Also man sollte auch über Hotmail-Accounts nicht irgendwie Banküberfallplanungen oder so schicken. Das wäre einfach zu lange nachweisbar.
Wie der Hack jetzt gelaufen ist, ist mir immer noch nicht klar. Also wenn du einloggst bei Hotmail, gibst du deinen Usernamen ein, dein Passwort und dann wird irgendein CGI aufgerufen.
Na dann kriegst du eine Session-ID und bist dann in dieser Session drin. Das heißt, du bist sozusagen bekannt.
Aber dieser Skript vergleicht erstmal Username und Passwort, was er irgendwo, Schiffgeld, wahrscheinlich abgelegt hat.
Genau und wenn es das verglichen hat, dann kriegst du halt eine Session-ID, also eine Nummer, die möglichst nicht zu raten ist. Und mit dieser Nummer in der URL kannst du dann weitermachen. Und wenn ich jetzt sozusagen eine Nummer rauskriegen würde, die dieser Server akzeptiert, dann könnte ich genau an deiner Stelle weitermachen. Ich könnte mit deinem hier weiterlesen. Und dieses Skript hat halt eine gültige, also wenn ich es jetzt richtig erinnere, dann war es eben eine gültige Session-Idee generiert. Und mit der konnte man dann sozusagen in Hotmail weitermachen.
Ah, super. Also man...
Also das war natürlich eine Verleitung.
Hat das irgendjemand von euch benutzt und ausprobiert?
Hat das funktioniert? Ich kenne jemanden, der hat es benutzt und es hat funktioniert.
Ich habe übrigens einen, ich habe eine Person gesprochen, die mir gesagt hat, dass er tatsächlich, also der mir gesagt hat, dass er tatsächlich, also er hat es auch gemacht und es hat auch funktioniert. Er ist wirklich an Mail-Accounts von Freunden nicht rangegangen, absichtlich. Das ich gar nicht wollte, was ich echt extrem okay fand.
Das ist auch so.
Hätte ich nicht gemacht.
Man will das nicht wissen.
Ich fand es schon immer eklig, Mail oder auch ganz normale Post von anderen Leuten zu lesen. Das interessiert mich wirklich nicht.
Kennst du das Gefühl, wenn du verpeilt auf einer Party stehst und du denkst gerade über irgendetwas nach und zwei Sekunden später fällt dir auf, dass du jetzt nicht gedacht hast, sondern es einfach gesagt hast.
Ein ganzes Verpeilt-Teil.
Und alle gucken dich komisch an.
Ja, so ist das halt ein bisschen mit E-Mails.
Ja, das ist nicht schön.
Was man nicht weiß, kann man auch nicht irgendwie aus Versehen...
Ja, also man sollte sich sozusagen das mit der E-Mail gut überlegen. Aber es gibt auch viele Leute, die gehen da sehr nachlässig um. Es gibt ja auch viele Leute, die installieren halt so Software, die nicht so gut funktioniert. Es gibt ja einen tollen MTA, Microsoft Exchange, der auch sehr bekannt ist für seinen ressourcenintensiven Betrieb und irgendwie seine sonstigen Securitymängel, die es noch so aufweist.
Reden wir doch über die guten Sachen.
Reden wir lieber über die guten Sachen.
Als nächstes steht aber hier Spam.
So, also wie E-Mail technisch abläuft, wissen wir.
Ist dir das klar geworden, Johnny? Hast du es verstanden?
Ich verstehe es komplett.
Könntest du es uns erklären?
Ich muss jetzt, ich werde, ja, ich kann es euch erklären. Ich werde jetzt erst mal herausfinden, wie man MTAs umkonfigurieren kann.
Ja genau, Sintmail zum Beispiel.
Das ist eine echte Herausforderung.
Man muss mal was uns einmal gemacht haben.
Das Schöne ist ja, was ich relativ früh, also ich finde ja Unix auch nach wie vor ein sehr spannendes Thema und habe das jahrelang irgendwie zur Seite gelegt. Jetzt versuche ich es gerade wieder ein bisschen. Und sehr spannend finde ich jetzt zum Beispiel, wie einfach es ja für den Provider ist, irgendwie zum Beispiel Alias einzurichten. Also dass ich halt sage, ich will nicht nur die Mail, die an johnny-at-orb.de kommt, sondern auch an johnny-häusler. Ja gut, ein Verwaltungsaufwand. Also wenn ich jetzt Tausende von Usern habe, dann ist das okay. Aber ich fand das vor einigen Jahren extrem spannend, dass das nicht so einfach war. Heute, wo ich weiß, wie einfach es ist, verstehe ich es nicht. Verwaltungsaufwand ist ja okay, aber...
Naja, also ich meine, ein Unix-System für viele viele tausend Leute zu administrieren, ist schon...
Ist das bestimmt nicht so richtig schlimm.
Nicht das, womit man gleich anfängt. Und gerade wenn es so bei Mail-Konfiguration geht, da gibt es so ein paar echt grausame Sachen. Also der älteste Vertreter dieser MTAs zum Beispiel ist Sendmail. Das Programm Sendmail ist einfach dafür bekannt, die wahrscheinlich unleserlichste Konfigurationsdatei auf diesem Planeten zu haben. Also das kommt gleich irgendwie nach weißes Rauschen.
Warum muss man sich auf so eine alten Programme eigentlich einigen? Wegen der Skripte, die dann alle gleich laufen, wenn sie auf Sendmail zugreifen.
Na ja, das ist halt auch installiert.
Es ist die gewachsene Software so. Sendmail ist halt einfach das Programm, mit dem Internet Mail groß geworden ist. Und das ist natürlich immer erweitert worden, alle können das.
Bei jedem Konfigurationsverhältnis.
Bei jedem Unix dabei.
Ganz spezielle Geschichte.
Ich dachte, bei Unix muss man alles selber installieren.
Nee, Sendmail kommt mit und gehört dazu. Es ist auch nicht so schlecht. Es kann nämlich wirklich alles. Das ist halt der Grund. Man kann mit Sendmail alles machen. Man kann irgendwie Faxgateways beschicken nach USB, Gatewayen und irgendwie was man machen möchte. Bloß die Konfigurationsdatei ist die Hölle.
Und das hat aber einen Grund. Das Ding musste mit wenig Speicher auskommen. Und das Konfigurationsfeld musste schnell passbar, also schnell umsetzbar sein in etwas. Es ist wie ein Quellcode. Es ist sozusagen ein Quellcode für den Mäler. Und der macht dann halt das, was da drin steht. Und damit er weiß, was er tun soll, muss er es einlesen und verarbeiten. Und das geht halt mit diesem Format irgendwie mit wenig Speicher, mit wenig Rechenleistung und das war der Grund, warum es so war.
Was ist das für ein Format, die Konfigurationsdatei?
Ascii, sendmail.ch, ein Ascii Lärm, den du auf dem Bild schon hast.
Mit vielen Dollars und Ws und DRODE-Zeichen und...
und Pro-CDs.
Aber es geht ja alles auch viel einfacher, nämlich wenn man schon Sendmail machen muss, dann sollte man M4 benutzen, jedenfalls am Anfang.
Was ist M4?
M4 ist so ein...
Makro-Generator.
Ein Programm, um Sourcecode zu generieren für Sendmail. Genau.
Wenn man Sendmail konfiguriert bekommt, gibt es sozusagen eine Art Übersetzung. Dummioser Interface.
Na ja, dummioser...
Relativ.
Ach ja.
Na ja, alles wäre ja so schön gewesen mit Mail, wenn nicht vor ein paar Jahren irgendwie diese Leute mit der zugeschnittenen Luftzufuhr zum Gehirn, weiß schon, die, die immer mit Krawatten rumlaufen, auf die tolle Idee gekommen wären. Oh, E-Mail, super, da können wir jetzt allen unsere neuen Preislisten schicken. Und am besten erzählen wir auch noch alles, was uns sonst noch, was sonst wir meinen, was wichtig ist, um uns reich zu machen. Und dann kam sie, die Sülze, die Spam.
Spam im Allgemeinen im Internet ein Ausdruck für Müll, Dreck, Werbung, unaufgeforderte, zugesandte Werbung vor allen Dingen. Und Spam ist irgendwie, kommt das eigentlich von Monty Python?
Ich bin nicht sicher.
Doch, es kommt daher. Es gibt einen Monty Python Song, der heißt Spam, Spam, Spam. Spam ist Dosenfleisch. Das ist dieses britische Fleisch in Dosen. So ein bisschen Kornbeef.
Spiceporked and ham.
Spiceporked and ham. Super. Und ich glaube, dass man das dafür benutzt, kommt... Ich glaube, es kommt von Monty Python aber ganz egal. Das nur als kurze Erklärung, was Spam überhaupt ist. Und wenn man sich mal fragt, woher die Leute eigentlich eure E-Mail-Adressen haben, also wenn ihr unaufgeforderte E-Mail-Werbung bekommt, unaufgefordert heißt, ihr habt euch dafür nicht in einen Newsletter-Service eintragen lassen oder in eine Mailing-Liste, sondern ihr bekommt plötzlich Werbung für... Was weiß ich. So bekommen sie eine Kreditkarte, auch wenn sie überhaupt kein Geld haben. Dann habt ihr höchstwahrscheinlich, also allerhöchstwahrscheinlich habt ihr eure E-Mail-Adresse irgendwann mal in euren Browser eingetragen. Oder in den Browser eingetragen. Ist das so einfach, die überm Browser rauszukriegen?
Na ja, es kommt darauf an, was für ein Browser man verwendet natürlich. Aber weil, ich glaube es gab nicht JavaScript irgendwie die Möglichkeit, die E-Mail-Adresse zu kriegen, indem man sich selbst eine E-Mail schickt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es immer noch geht, aber...
Aber erinnere dich, vorhin haben wir gesagt, es gibt große Computer, wo viel Mails durchgehen. Für tausend Leute, da fliegen die E-Mail-Adressen die ganzen Tage an ihrer Nase vorbei. Sie brauchen sie eigentlich nur auf die Festplatte zu schreiben und genau das tun sie eigentlich auch. Deswegen gibt es auch überhaupt diese Web. Ich meine, warum sollte Microsoft irgendjemandem was schenken? Ich meine, Hotmail nachdenken kostet zwar nichts, aber es gibt natürlich schon einen Grund. Weil sie machen damit Geld, diese Adressen zu haben und vor allem massig Profile darüber zu generieren, was da eigentlich getan wird. Wer schickt wann, wie oft, wie viel, Mails an wen, was steht drin, welche Worte werden gerne benutzt, welches Alter haben die Teilnehmer und so weiter und so weiter und so weiter.
Wobei du doch bei den meisten Web-Services irgendeinen Quatsch eintragen kannst.
Da gibt es aber mittlerweile auch Abweichungen, insbesondere Web.de hat hier für ihr Free-Mail-Konzept, das ist auch so was wie Hotmail. Nur gibt es dort Verschlüsselung, um die Identität des Users zu prüfen. Schicken Sie an die angegebene Adresse eine Postkarte mit einem Identifikationscode, der dann auf der Webseite eingetragen werden muss.
Eine Postkarte?
Eine Postkarte, drucken das Ding aus, frankieren das und ab.
Und jeder Postbote kann es lesen?
Und jeder Postbote kann es lesen. Das ist natürlich irgendwie minder sinnvoll, aber es ist zumindest garantiert, dass die Postadresse gesichert ist. Also es existiert dieser Mail-Drop, wo die Postkarte ankommt. Oder aber der Beriefträger nimmt sich das halt mit.
Machst du das GMX nicht über eine andere Mail-Adresse? Also dass du so eine Haupt-Mail-Adresse... Ich hab mal ein GMX-Account ausgefüllt, aber ich kann mich nicht mehr erinnern, weil ich es in die Benutzung...
Nein, die schicken aber keine Postkarten. Die schicken nur eine E-Mail, um festzustellen, ob deine Haupt-E-Mail-Adresse existiert. Das machen aber Mailinglisten auch, zu denen kommen wir später noch. Was ich noch sagen wollte, zu News Server. News Server sind natürlich ein sehr probates Mittel, um Adressen zu sammeln, da ja dort eben hochgradig fein detailliert wird in Interessensgebieten. Also es gibt mittlerweile, whatever, x Nummern, x verschiedene Diskussionsforen und...
Tausende.
In jedem dieser Diskussionsforen posten ja eigentlich nur die Leute, die thematisch sich mit dem befassen. Oder halt Leute, die da Spam reinschicken, aber deren Absenderadressen sind meistens eh ungültig. Und hier ist natürlich möglich, einfach relativ leichtes abzugreifen, weil ja Newt, wie wir vorher gesagt haben, im Gegensatz zu privater Mail, öffentlicher Mail ist.
Das ist auch auf der legalen Seite dann genau der Schritt gewesen, weil es gab vor ein paar Jahren diesen Fall eines Rechtsanwaltes, da kommen wir dann zum Begriff Cross-Posting und Spam in Newsgroups. Also auch in Newsgroups waren früher...
Pff, nein, irgendwie so ein alter Sack.
Waren einfach so, dass sie wirklich nur themenbezogen waren, also dass man sich wirklich nur über dieses Thema unterhalten hat. Weiß nicht, über die Videotreiber von einer bestimmten Videokarte von mir aus. Wer sich dafür interessiert, der könnte halt mit Leuten darüber reden.
Oder die Lieder von Kate Bush.
Zum Beispiel, ganz egal. Oder, weiß nicht, den rechten großen C der Schwiegermutter. Oder irgendwie so eine Sache. Also es gibt auch sehr lustige Newsgroups, muss man dazu sagen.
Zum Beispiel alt.fan.wesleycryer.dai.dai.
Es gab auch diesen komischen Barney, dieses Kindermonster. Barney.kill.kill.kill. Auch sehr hübsch. Zum Beispiel Best of Internet war eine tolle Newsgroups jahrelang. Und die sind inzwischen nur noch voll mit, also wirklich Leute, die die witzigsten Sachen aus dem Internet gesammelt haben und die beklopptesten Homepages und so weiter. Voll mit Werbung.
Best of Internet?
Altpunkt, Bestpunkt.
Auf Internet.
Das war vor ein paar Jahren ein guter Hinweis für klassische Adressen. Da ist jedenfalls nur noch Werbung drin. Das ist eigentlich in Anführungszeichen verboten. Also das ist einfach, das geht gegen die Etikett.
Aber es gibt noch was schlimmeres als Spam.
Warte, ich wollte ganz kurz noch die legale Seite davon. Nachdem die ersten Leute dann gegen E-Mail-Werbung zum Beispiel geklagt haben und gesagt haben, meine E-Mail-Adresse wird hier benutzt, obwohl ich dazu keine Einverständnis gegeben habe, haben die Hersteller von diesen Mailing-Listen, von diesen Spam-Mailing-Listen gesagt, wieso, du postest in Newsgroups, die sind öffentlich, das heißt, du gibst deine Adresse öffentlich jedem bekannt, also auch uns. Und du könntest von jedem Mail kriegen, also warum nicht auch von uns, und damit sind sie vor Gerichten durchgekommen. Und seitdem kann man sich zumindest auf diesem Weg nicht mehr gegen Spam wehren. Das sind allerdings einige Gesetze in Vorbereitung oder Versuchen. Es gibt immer wieder Versuche da Gesetze durchzukriegen.
Cyberpromo-Menschen, die haben sie ganz schön fertig gemacht, oder?
Das war dieser Anwalt damals?
Anwalt, der Cyberpromo war halt die erste Firma, die so richtig rüpelhaft aufgefallen ist. Also die massiv jedem und allen permanent von vorne bis hinten mit ekliger Mail zugegossen hat. Und dem haben sie, ich weiß nicht, ich bin jetzt über den rechtlichen Hergang der Sache überhaupt nicht vertraut.
Irgendwann hätte er keinen Profiler mehr.
Ja, den mochte dann auch niemand mehr, genau. Also am Schluss wollte ihn einfach auch keiner mehr haben.
Dann waren alle doof.
Es gibt so viele.
Der Internetpranger.
Es reicht ja auch, ich meine, die Amis mit ihrem Free Speech und so, die hoffen ja immer, die legen immer Wert darauf, dass sich alles selber regulieren soll. Und das hat eine Zeit lang auch funktioniert. Und das tut es dann ja in einzelnen Fällen auch tatsächlich.
Da ist auch was dran. Ich meine, was nämlich noch schlimmer ist als die Spam, sind die Maßnahmen, die technischen Maßnahmen, die danach ergriffen wurden, um diese Spam automatisch zu unterbinden.
Stimmt.
Also man hat jetzt massiv Systeme installiert, die halt versuchen zu erkennen, dass es sich hierbei um eine Mail handelt, die derjenige, der sie erhalten soll, eigentlich gar nicht erhalten will.
Weil sich ja gezeigt hat, dass eben die Möglichkeit des Filterns nur durch technische Möglichkeiten gegeben war und eben nicht durch legale Grundlagen, die dafür da waren. Zwar ist es mittlerweile in Deutschland wohl so, dass es behandelt wird wie ein unverlangt zugestelltes Fax, dem Empfänger entstehen Kosten, insofern darf der Abziner das nicht tun. Das Problem ist natürlich, dass niemand wegen ein paar Spam-Mails versucht internationale Amtshilfe zu beantragen. Das Problem ist, wenn der Spammer in irgendeinem, was weiß ich, Mio an Mars sitzt, dann kann ihn natürlich die deutsche Rechtsprechung nicht deswegen angreifen und deshalb wurden technische Methoden entwickelt, um das auszufiltern. Die filtern aber leider auch sinnvolle Mail aus.
Weil sich hauptsächlich an bestimmte Adressen orientieren, oder?
Ja, oder auch nach Schlagwörtern, nach Kontext. Begriffen wie z.B. Dollar Dollar Dollar. Und die halt nicht in der Lage sind zu unterscheiden, ob das nun Spam ist.
Das heißt, wenn der jemand die Konfigurationsdatei von Sendmail schickt, dann wird die wahrscheinlich rausgefiltert.
Also in News ist das zum Beispiel ein echtes Problem, weil da haben halt auch tierisch viele, wie du schon gesagt hast, so Werbung in die Rubriken reingegossen. Und tja, was haben dann die Administratoren gemacht? Die haben dann irgendwie gesagt, also hier auf unseren News Server sowieso mal nur Leute, denen wir irgendwie auch den Kanal abdrehen können. Und auf einmal, was halt früher nicht üblich war, waren die News Server nicht mehr public erreichbar. Das heißt, man kann zwar an dem einem zugeteilten News Server lesen und man kann da auch irgendwie schreiben, aber eben nicht bei einem anderen. Was voraussetzt, dass dein News Server auch alle News Gruppen vorrätig hat, überhaben willst, was nicht unbedingt gegeben ist. Man möchte manchmal auch mit anderen News Server machen, wenn die halt nicht explizit offiziell sind, öffentlich sind, sondern eben gesperrt sind, um diese Spam-Geschichte zu verhindern, dann ist das halt schon mal eine Einschränkung. Also man merkt das vor allem, wenn man viel umherzieht, mit dem Laptop, sich von unterschiedlichen Orten ans Netz ranklingt und dann immer seine Server benutzen möchte. Dann kann man die auf einmal nicht benutzen, nur wenn man auf einmal auf der anderen Seite vom Internet steht. Und das ist alles das große Elend. Also Spam hat einfach ganz ähnliche Folgen gehabt.
Ja, und da gibt es ja dann auch doch ein paar Leute, die sich andere Sachen haben einfallen lassen. Es gibt zum Beispiel in Sachen Newscoupes die Möglichkeit, sich zu beschweren. Es gibt Abuse-Adressen. Manchmal für manche Newscoupes, die bringen angeblich manchmal auch ein bisschen was. Also das Problem an Spam ist natürlich immer der Absender. Wenn das alles echte E-Mail-Adressen wären, dann wäre das ja alles nicht so ein Problem. Dann könnte man auch Leute zur Verantwortung ziehen. Aber sind sie natürlich nicht, weil Leute ja nicht blöd sind.
Na ja, technisch liese sich aber eben auf dem Weg über diesen Weg, den die Mail genommen hat, die im Header verfügbar ist, feststellen, wer denn der Absenderrechner war. Das Problem hierbei ist, dass natürlich der Provider, bei dem dieser Rechner steht, nicht zwangsläufig die Logfiles herausgeben muss. Man kann ihn zwar darum bitten, er wird das in manchen Fällen auch tun. Im Regelfall ist es so, dass die, um die Anonymität ihrer User oder die Privatsphäre ihrer User zu schützen, ihre Logfiles nicht herausgeben. Und somit kann eben nicht festgestellt werden, wer zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt welchen Rechner verwendet hat.
Das ist doch auch, ich mein, hier, also der Chaos Computer Club setzt sich ja sowieso mit der Privatsphäre im Netz und so viel auseinander. Aber das ist doch so ein bisschen die Krux bei diesem ganzen Kram. Oder in dem Moment, wo alle sich eine gewisse Etikette halten und so, da funktioniert das alles wunderbar. In dem Moment, wo Leute Sachen missbrauchen, steht man auch plötzlich dann auch an einem Punkt, wo man sagt, den hätten wir jetzt aber gerne, weil der Müll hier alles voll. Stehen wir jetzt zu der Geschichte mit Privatsphäre und man darf eben nicht ans Leder oder müssen wir da neue Regelungen einführen? Also ist das für euch ein Problem? Dass man da irgendwie plötzlich hin und her schwankt?
Ich denke vor allem von der Größenordnung ab. Also wenn jemand in großem Maße Spam betreibt, wird man natürlich versuchen, das abzustellen. Man wird auch versuchen, Maßnahmen zu ergreifen, damit so etwas nicht wieder geschieht. Aber wegen einer einzelnen Mail so eine Aktion zu starten und eben bewusst in Kauf zu nehmen, die Privatsphäre von Usern anzugreifen. Denke ich, muss man im Einzelfall abwägen und kommt eben an, wie schwer der Verstoß war?
Dadurch das, was man vielleicht als Spannungsfeld bezeichnet. Wo man halt auch wirklich abwägen muss, aber wo auf gar keinen Fall die große Pauke, das ist jetzt verboten und das ist jetzt bestraft. Ich habe zum Beispiel die Möglichkeit, meine E-Mail-Adresse eigentlich im Prinzip frei zu bestimmen. In dem Moment, wo ich die Mail abschicke, sage ich, dem Weiterleitungsprogramm von welcher E-Mail-Adresse das ist. Es gibt da keinerlei Verifikation.
Manche Provider verifizieren das, oder?
Ja, nehmen sie halt oder umständen nicht an, wenn es keine Adresse in ihrem Bereich ist. Oder ich weiß nicht, ob sie auch wirklich jetzt eine Account-Prüfung machen, das glaube ich aber nicht. Das ist auf jeden Fall auch schon mal so eine Auswirkung von irgendwie Spam-Reglementierung. Aber ich möchte das halt manchmal explizit, weil ich irgendwie mehrere E-Mail-Adressen habe, die auch in einem anderen Domain, vielleicht in meinem eigenen Domain sind. Und dann nehmen die halt die Mail nicht an, die doofen Teile. Das ist einfach zum Heulen. Also wenn man nicht irgendwie seinen eigenen Computer hat im Internet, so dann kann man eigentlich nicht wirklich Mail machen.
Auweia, wir hatten acht Minuten lang Musik, EGIT und das ist ein Chaosradio.
Wir haben uns so interessant unterhalten.
Die Themen wurden gerade, jetzt wurden sie gerade interessant. Können wir da nicht weiter reden? Also.
Was haben wir gerade gesagt?
Verschlüsselung. Wir haben gerade gesagt, dass es sowieso alles Quatsche ist oder immer nur eine SSL-Page nützt, gar nichts, wenn danach eine Mail verschickt wird. Jetzt wollte ich aber bei Hushmail doch mal gucken, ob die was dazu sagen.
Hushmail. H-U-S-H-H-Mail, richtig?
Ich habe Tausende E-Mails geschickt und habe sie noch nie entkrypt. Warum brauche ich entkrypte E-Mails?
Die behaupten halt, dass sie irgendwie verschlüsselte E-Mail machen.
Was aber nicht stimmt, das Konzept an sich ist mal ganz interessant. Sie bieten eben verschlüsselte Mail von sich aus an. Dieser Swap-Interface ist auch nur über einen SSL-gesicherten Zugang zu erreichen. Die Mail, die man dort schreibt, wird auch bis zu deren Server verschlüsselt übertragen, nur um sie einem anderen Teilnehmer zuzustellen, muss sie den üblichen Weg nehmen, dass wir SMTP und er ist wieder unverschlüsselt.
Aber PGP ist da nicht mit drin.
Zumal es halt keine Clients gibt, auf denen der Ziel, der Empfänger, irgendwie dann diese haschmehre entschlüsseln könnte. Das ist halt das Problem.
Da wird halt viel behauptet.
Naja, wobei, also sie sagen es nicht so richtig deutlich, aber sie sagen schon, worum es geht. Sie sagen, dass SSL benutzen, SSL-Encryption, zwischen deinem Computer und unserem Server. Und dann, wenn der Bezüger ist, oder sagt man Recipient, keine Ahnung, Recipient. Ist ein Usenet, der SSL-Encryption, wird auch deine Beziehungen zwischen unserem Server und deinem Computer schützen. Na klar. Also alles, was da auf dem Server bleibt, ist natürlich der Encryption.
Ja, und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, einem beliebigen User im Internet schreiben zu wollen, der dann zufällig bei haschmehren einen Account hat, ist relativ gering.
Ja, und selbst wenn er da einen Account hat, dann ist halt haschmail, dieser Server, irgendwie genau der Punkt, an dem man die Mails unverschließt kriegt.
Und wo sie natürlich auch der Serverbetreiber mitlesen kann. Man weiß ja auch nicht von wem der stammt, ob der zum Beispiel von der US-Regierung stammt. Die Firma befindet sich zwar in Antigua außerhalb des Einflusses von US-Gesetzesbehörden, nur die Server befinden sich physikalisch in Kanada in der Nähe der amerikanischen Grenze.
Weil da die dickeren Gasfaser leiden.
Jo, jetzt haben wir gleich das Fritz-Kurz-Info. Das heißt, wir können jetzt noch nicht über Attachments reden. Ihr könnt euch aber schon mal für euch zu Hause die Nummer aufschreiben, die wir haben im Studio. Denn demnächst werdet ihr natürlich hier dabei sein. Die Nummer ist 0331 für Potsdam 7097110.
Watch your waist, see the line.
Falk ist ja eigentlich bisher bewusst gewesen, dass die gesamte E-Mail, die du hier schreibst, total unsicher ist und dass ich die jeden Tag mitlese. Ne, echt?
Was?
Ich muss sagen, das ist echt eine Sau, ja. Aber ich mag dich jetzt noch mehr. Aber die Geschichte mit dem Hamster, da müssen wir nochmal drüber.
Wenn Fritz rund um Corpus, dann 103, 2.
23.30 Uhr.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Demonstrationen. In zahlreichen Städten Serbiens setzte die Opposition am Abend ihre Protestmärsche gegen die Politik des jugoslawischen Präsidenten Milošević fort. In Belgrad hat die Polizei einen Protestmarsch von rund 25.000 Demonstranten gewaltsam aufgelöst. Aufschub. Die Bundesregierung hat heute ihren Beschluss vertagt, 100 deutsche Sanitätssoldaten nach Osttimo zu schicken. Zum einen ist die Truppenentsendung in der Koalition umstritten, zum anderen ist die Finanzierung noch unklar. Stellungnahme. Der SPD-Landesvorstand in Brandenburg hat sich am Abend für den Koalitionsvertrag mit der CDU ausgesprochen. Dem SPD-Sonderparteitag am 4. Oktober wurde somit die Bildung einer großen Koalition empfohlen. Konflikt. Ein Einmarsch russischer Truppen in Tschechien wird immer wahrscheinlicher. Nach einer Woche massiver Bombenangriffe ist ein erster Gesprächsversuch der russischen Regierung mit der Führung der abtrünnigen Kaukasusrepublik gescheitert.
Sport.
Fußball. In der Champions League spielten am Abend Borussia Dortmund beim norwegischen Vertreter Rosenborg Trondheim 2 zu 2. Bayer Leverkusen und Dynamo Kiew trennten sich 1 zu 1. Nachtszeit war es Regen um 12 Grad. Morgen bewölkt gelegentlich Regen. Tageshöchsttemperatur 17 bis 20 Grad.
Verkehr.
Wir schauen immer noch alle Fußball, weil Verkehrsmeldungen gibt es immer noch nicht.
Das war ein Fritz-Kurzentrum mit Falk Zielke.
Samstag, 2.
Oktober im Gladhouse in Cottbuss.
Präsentiert von Fritz.
Weiter geht's im Chaosradio, da wir uns gerade ein bisschen verquatscht haben. Wollen wir gleich weitermachen einfach? Also Telefone sind offen schon mal. 0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Genau, wenn ihr Fragen zu E-Mail habt.
Genau, Fragen zu E-Mail oder noch was dazu. Zu den Themen Attachments kommen wir noch zum Thema Verschlüsseln, Sicherheit oder Anonymität kommen wir gleich auch noch und fangen dann eigentlich gleich damit an, oder? Oder erst Attachments?
Attachments? Ja, das ist ja auch noch so ein Annoyment. Eine Einzelneuens. Irgendwann ging es halt los und alle haben halt Netscape benutzt, um ihre E-Mails zu verschicken. Und da Netscape ja irgendwie damit angefangen hat, eigentlich HTML anzuzeigen, sind sie dann auch gleich auf die tolle Idee gekommen, die Möglichkeit zu schaffen, Mails zu verschicken, die im Wesentlichen aus HTML bestehen, wo also der Text nicht als Rotext drin steht.
Aber da reden wir jetzt nicht über Attachments, oder? Dann liegt es da länger.
Naja, also das ist eigentlich dasselbe. Also wenn du eine Datei an deine Mail ranhängst, dann ist das genauso, als wenn du HTML an deine Datei ranhängst. Das ist nämlich genau der Knackpunkt. Also eine Mail im klassischen Sinne ist einfach nur roher Text, ohne irgendwelche Formatierungen, einfach nur ASCII, 7-Bit, sonst gar nichts. Und so betreiben die allermeisten Leute eigentlich Mail, kurze Textnachrichten. Und mit den intelligenter werdenden User-Agents, so wie Netscape zum Beispiel, wurde es halt dann immer leichter möglich, auch HTML mitzuschicken, Bilder mit ranzuhängen, Programme zu verschicken, ZIP-Dateien, was auch immer. Also beliebige Dateien oder eben auch die Mail selber in einem anderen Format darzustellen. Also was noch ein bisschen widerlicher ist, als seine Mails in HTML zu verschicken, ist ein Word-Dokument mit an die Mail ranzuhängen und da die eigentliche Mail mit rein zu tun, weil man dabei immer davon ausgeht, dass derjenige, der die Mail erhält, auch das lesen kann. Also nicht jeder verwendet ein Mail-Reder. Das ist Knisterndirr. Wenn ich einen Mail-Reder verwende, der nur normal Textmails anzeigen kann und mir schickt jemand eine Mail, wo der Textteil einfach leer ist und der ganze Inhalt der Mail steht aber in dem Attachment in HTML, dann kann ich das halt nicht lesen. Es sei denn, ich lade mir das in ein Texteditor, denk mir das HTML weg und es ist halt einfach elend.
Oder du schaltest den Header ein und hast dann im Header diesen ganzen HTML-Drag.
Nee, im Header hast du ihn nicht.
Doch.
Nee, im Body.
Dann ist dein Mail-User-Engine scheiße.
Also manchmal, der Body sieht eigentlich, also mit Inattachment sieht ein Body eigentlich aus wie ein Header, weil er total übersiebt ist mit komischen Zeichen.
Das kenn ich auch, wenn du im Body die Text hast. Aber ich krieg inzwischen, also ich benutze Eudora als Client und ich krieg inzwischen Mails, die sind leer und ich weiß genau, dann muss ich oben in Eudora, um den Header sichtbar zu machen, dieses Blablabla Zeichen. Und wenn du den anschreitest, siehst du den HTML Text.
Na dann kann es sein, dass irgendwie die Leerzeile gefehlt hat, die eigentlich zwischen Header und Body ist.
Also dann stellt er alle Attachments dar, die er auch eigentlich nicht darstellen kann, als Romano Text.
Oder Eudora sieht das vielleicht so, dass das in den Header gehört.
Ich glaub, das ist Outlook. Wenn du, also das muss man wirklich mal sagen, tut uns, also tut mir bitte eingefallen, wenn ihr Outlook als Mail-Client benutzt, auf eurem Computer zum Mail schreiben und so, da gibt es irgendwo in den Optionen, es ist leider angekreuzt, dass die Mails als HTML verschickt werden. Wenn man da ankreuzt, nur Text, macht ihr mich total glücklich. Weil HTML-Mail fliegt echt sofort weg.
Du kennst das Problem. Genau.
Ich kenn noch ein anderes Problem. Ich finde das immer ganz hübsch, weil ich doch eine Menge Praxis hab, was Mail angeht. Ich erkenne noch ein anderes Problem. Plattenfirmen, gerne auch kleinere Labels, die unaufgefordert Mailing-Listen verschicken mit ihren neuen Releases. Was erstmal noch okay wäre, wenn sie nicht alle Adressaten ins CC-Feld packen. Das fliegt auch sofort weg. Da muss man vielleicht auch mal ein Wort sagen. Tu ist der Adressat der Mail. CC, Doppelpunkt, steht für Carbon Copy, was ungefähr so viel ist wie eine Blaupause. Das heißt, es sind weitere Empfänger, die diese Mail bekommen sollen. Der Hauptempfänger der Mail, der hinter Tu steht und auch die, die hinter CC stehen, die E-Mail-Adressen, die können alle die jeweils anderen Adressen auch sehen, wenn sie diese Mail bekommen. Das heißt, sie wissen, dass andere Leute diese Mail auch bekommen haben. Im BCC, was für Blind Carbon Copy steht, wird die Information nicht übertragen. Also wenn ihr irgendwie eine Plattenfirma seid und Listen verschickt mit euren neuen Releases oder so, dann tragt ihr diese ganzen Namen ins BCC-Feld ein oder noch besser benutzt Mailing-Liste.
Ja, und vor allem tragt auch den eigentlichen Adressanten bei Tor, damit man zumindest weiß, über welche E-Mail-Adresse man den ganzen Kram bekommt. Ach, es ist schlimm mit diesen Mime. Ich meine, es ist eigentlich eine tolle Idee, Mime-Mails, also das muss auch gehen, so dass man dann auch Multimedia-Mails schicken kann. Ja, und auch Umlaute. Ja gut, aber Mime brauchst du nicht für Umlaute.
Doch.
Du brauchst Mime für Umlaute?
Content-Encoding.
Ach, das Content-Encoding muss codiert sein und das ist...
Ja, also mittlerweile ist es so, dass die meisten MTAs auf 8-Bit-Clean sind, das heißt 8-Bit-Characters durchlassen im Buddy, ohne irgendwie zu merken, aber eigentlich ist das Content-Encoding quoted, printable.
Das ist Bestandteil von der Mime-Spezifikation. Aber was kommt denn manchmal noch so mit? Ähm, Wörttokument, wir hatten es ja schon gesagt. Das wird natürlich nur noch ein besonderes Problem.
Makrovieren.
Manchmal aus deiner jüngsten Vergangenheit richten.
Ich kann echt immer nur wieder dazu aufhören. Es ist leider bei uns nicht wirklich zu machen, aber ich hab wirklich gedacht, ich benutze einfach nichts mehr, wo Microsoft mit zu tun hat. Nichts mehr. Die Tatsache, dass eine Firma eine Software so lange weiter herstellt und mit dem Bewusstsein darüber, dass da superleicht Viren und ausführbare Programme zumindest auf einem PC zu implementieren sind, durch Makros, die Firma kann einfach nur ein Rad abkommen.
It's not a bug. So sehen die das.
Wie viel kommerzielle Antivirus-Software stellt Microsoft selber her? Wahrscheinlich mit gutem Grund. Oder hat gekauft. Egal, aber das ist ein kleiner Abstecher in mein tägliches Leben.
Die haben heimlich Anteil.
Ja, also Makroviren. Das ist jetzt wieder ein anderes Problem, was mit Mail zunächst gar nichts zu tun haben sollte. Es gab vor einigen Jahren so einen Dauer-Joke auf dem Internet, der sich auch immer noch sehr gut hält. Der ist bekannt unter dem Namen GoodTimesVirus. Das ist eine Mail, die irgendwie alle Leute mal erreicht hat, die ja so weitgehend durch die Welt geschoben wurde. Und alle haben sie auch gleich weitergeleitet, die vor einem Virus GoodTimes irgendwie wart. Und man soll bloß nicht diese Mail jetzt lesen, wenn da GoodTimes drin steht, weil da hat man sofort ein Virus auf seinem Computer. Naja, das war halt ein guter Hoax, das war ein guter Witz. Weil alle haben es geglaubt und alle haben es sofort an alle anderen weitergeleitet, um alle anderen zu warnen. Bis sie dann gemerkt haben, dass eigentlich dieser Text selber der Virus ist, weil alle Leute ihn einfach weiterleiten.
Und den gibt es aber immer noch. Kriegt man regelmäßig. Und das ist auch total süß, finde ich, weil jeder, der einen neuen Internet-Account hat, der kriegt vielleicht eine Mail von einem Kumpel und dann drei Tage später kriegt er mal eine Mail, weil er sich in ein Newsletter eingetragen hat. Und plötzlich kommt diese Viruswarnung aus dem Internet, aus Amerika. Und ich mein's wirklich total nett, weil ich kann's wirklich verstehen, denn ich hab's natürlich auch gemacht und man denkt, das verschicke ich jetzt an alle beiden anderen E-Mails, die ich habe. Und die verschicken's dann auch an die beiden anderen. Und man denkt so, jetzt bin ich Teil der Internet-Gemeinde und ich hab einem geholfen. Und spätestens, wenn man dieses Ding dann 800 Mal zurückgekriegt hat, dann weiß man, scheiße, hier stimmt was mit.
Genau, und Hinweise auf eine Webseite, wo erklärt ist, was das tatsächlich ist. Naja, also dieser GoTimes-Virus, das Lustige war, danach fragten natürlich auch alle uns, ob denn das geht. Und wir guckten uns irgendwie die aktuelle Lage an und meinten so, alles totaler Quatsch, geht nicht. Und es ging auch nicht. Mit der damaligen Technologie war das einfach nicht möglich, dass man eine E-Mail kriegt und nur weil man sie liest, hat man auf einmal ein Virus. Und alle konnten mit Fug und Recht behaupten, dass es das nicht gab. Und dann kam Microsoft und hat Makros für Word-Dokumente eingeführt. Und damit war das einfach mal alles am Ende. Und seitdem kann man nämlich genau das tun. Also sehr wohl kann einem das Lesen einer E-Mail irgendwie Software einhandeln. Wenn der Computer schlecht konfiguriert ist, wenn die Mail wirklich angreifen möchte und irgendwie in einem Fall von 10.000. Passiert nicht jeden Tag, aber konnte dann halt wirklich gehen. Das ist eben so eine Sache mit In-Detachment. Das Problem ist, dass natürlich wenig Leute wirklich wissen können, so diesen Komplexitätsgrad, den das an der Stelle hat.
Und auch nicht wissen müssen sollten. Da sind wir halt wieder bei so einem Punkt, der ja öfter mal durchsickert. Also wenn man sich so anguckt, was für komplexe E-Commerce-Systeme zum Beispiel geplant sind, wenn man sich überlegt, auf welcher technischen Grundlage das inzwischen alles basiert. Also meistens inzwischen bei den Servern noch ganz viel auf Windows NT. Ich stelle mir diese ganzen Applikationen immer so vor wie so eine umgedrehte Pyramide, die nur so auf der Spitze steht und je mehr man oben drauf baut, desto wackeliger wird die natürlich. Und so sehe ich viele Sachen im Internet zurzeit. Man ist natürlich da wieder an einem Punkt, wo man sagt, das können die meisten User nicht wissen. Das Internet war wahrscheinlich auch nie dafür gebaut, dass es so viele kommerzielle Anwendungen hat. Das war nie die Idee und es war auch nie die Idee, dass man da ein High-End-User-Interface hat, wo alles super einfach ist. Sondern es war ein technisches Netzwerk.
So ist es.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz wäre es möglich, das alles auf eine richtige Pyramide zu stellen.
Stimmt, wenn wir Microsoft-Produkte nicht mehr benutzen.
Aber man muss das ja nicht tun.
Microsoft ist ja auch nur ein Teil. Eigentlich haben alle Firmen derzeit ein kräftiges Problem. Sie wollen alle Kohle verdienen und alle schreien nach Internet. Also müssen sie da irgendwas liefern. Und programmieren sie sich da den Hengst und natürlich wollen sie unbedingt E-Commerce machen. Und wir machen es auch und wir machen es uns auch. Und irgendwie First-to-Market. Und wenn man irgendwie nur zwei Monate vorher mit irgendeinem Produkt angefangen hat, dann wird man drei Monate später von irgendeinem Megakonzern aufgekauft. Und die Aktien schießen in die Höhe. Und es sind alle einfach total mega hektisch. Und wenn man so hektisch drauf ist, kann man einfach keine ordentliche Software programmieren. Das ist halt einfach die Wahrheit. Und sehr schön ist es dann auch immer wieder zu sehen, was eigentlich tatsächlich verwendet wird, um die wirklich kritischen Teile zu fahren. Eben nicht diese ganzen neuen Megaprodukte und so. Also Microsoft hat auch im Internet eigentlich nicht viel etablierte Systeme. Also da laufen vielleicht ein paar Web-Server drauf. Aber so als die Mega-Routing-Maschinen, die halt das ganze Netz überhaupt zusammenhalten, werden eigentlich immer noch Unix-Systeme eingesetzt.
Wir diskutieren gerade, ob wir zu technisch sind oder ob wir zu viel reden oder zu wenig.
Sind wir zu technisch oder nicht? Wir hören euch nicht.
Falls noch jemand wach ist, könnt ihr ja mal anrufen. 031-0331-70-97-110. Ansonsten reden wir jetzt über, wo wir bei Attachments, wir haben doch nicht einmal gesagt, dass Attachments Anhängsel sind, obwohl man es vielleicht verstehen könnte von Wort her, aber dass man halt mit der Mail, mit dem reinen Text zusammen dann auch noch zum Beispiel ein Programm oder eine Datei einfach anhängen kann.
Ein Anhang.
Genau, du hast so recht. Du hast so unglaublich recht. Also wenn ihr an eure Post einen Anhang schickt, dann kann das unangenehme Folgen haben bei den Leuten, die es lesen, wenn sie nicht in der Lage sind, den Anhang zu lesen. Oder wenn ihr in dem Anhang ein Virus drin habt oder irgendwas Stimmes, wie auch immer. Also Mail ist eigentlich eine ganz praktische Sache. Aber es gibt da noch was Praktischeres, um seine Zeit tot zu schlagen, nämlich Mailinglisten.
Jetzt haben wir ganz viele Anrufer hier. Echt? Wollen wir erst mal vor den Mailinglisten reingehen?
Ja, ist vielleicht besser.
Hi, hier ist Chaosradio. Wer ist denn da?
Ich habe eine Frage. Hat Packetradio viel zu tun mit dem Internet?
Ob Packetradio viel mit dem Internet zu tun hat, fragst du.
Genau.
Habe ich deine Frage richtig verstanden? Zunächst einmal ist Packetradio eine Technik, mit der du über Funk Datenpakete übertragen kannst. Das kann man für viele Sachen benutzen. Mittlerweile machen sie auch Internet damit.
Was das?
Alter, da ist der Packetradio-Retan.
Hi, hier ist Chaosradio. Wer ist denn da? Doch, eingeschlafen. Hier ist das Chaosradio. Wer ist denn da? Hallo, Matthias.
Ich wollte mal sagen, wegen dem Primae krieg ich mal einen Brief und keine Karte. Und ich habe mal eine Frage wegen dem Best-of.
Das ist eine Newsgroup. Also es ist keine WWW-Adresse, sondern eine Newsgroup. Und die hat die Adresse haltpunktbest.of.internet. Bitte.
Da muss man da ein Newsdoppelpunkt davor eingehen.
Dann gibt man die, wenn alles wichtig konfiguriert ist.
Man hat ja News Server eingetragen.
Das haben die meisten Leute nicht.
Guckt, ob ihr einen News Server eingetragen habt in eurem Programm. Zum Beispiel Netzcape. Im Notfall einfach probieren. Hat einen in der Regel.
News.provider.de Genau.
News.Snafu.de oder whatever. Wo ihr gerade seid. Und dann könnt ihr auch News lesen. Zum Beispiel das Beste vom Internet.
Oder ihr benutzt, wenn ihr communiciert, ihr benutzt, ihr hat einen News Group Reader, glaube ich.
Ja, du kannst aber die URL trotzdem navigiert eingeben.
Und es gibt dann so web-based Newsreader auch, es gibt Deja-News, es gibt...
Deja-News wechselt ja permanent irgendwie sein Gesicht. Jetzt ist das schon so richtig irgendwie... Do it before you buy steht da jetzt irgendwie drunter. Also jetzt soll man irgendwie mal ins News-System reingehen, wenn man was kaufen möchte. Also sie sind auch schamlos. Erst hatten sie irgendwie ein dickes, fettes News-Archiv und jetzt ist das Ganze irgendwie verborgen hinter einer komischen, kommerziellen Oberfläche mit irgendwie willst du Scheiße kaufen, dann guck doch erst mal hier nach, was sie kostet. Also totaler Blödsinn.
Na ja, man kann es aber immer noch so benutzen wie früher auch. Ich tu das nun wieder.
Muss man sich da jetzt nicht immer ein Login geben lassen?
Nein.
Nur für bestimmte News-Clubs, Tim.
Ach echt?
Und zwar war das auch bei Hotmail, worüber ihr euch ja lustig macht. Und zwar habe ich einfach mal einen, deren E-Mail-Adresse ich mal über so ein, irgend so ein Spam gekriegt habe. Keine Ahnung, wie das da reinkam. Habe ich einfach eine E-Mail zurückgeschrieben. Hab gefragt, wer diejenige oder derjenige sei. Dann kam da irgend so eine verdammte Mail zurück. Und dann ist auch so was wie eine E-Mail-Freundschaft daraus geworden. Und jetzt war aber das Problem, dass irgendjemand sich da auch reingehängt hat und dann geschrieben hat, du hast was mit der und was willst du, ey? Und so völlig brutal hat er das dann auf meinem eigenen Account mir selber in Nordmedien die Adresse geschickt. Und ich weiß auch, wie man dieser Hotmail-Hack ging so, dass man über JavaScripts kommen wurde der ja bekannt und da konnte man das dann halt ausführen und es war wohl ganz einfach.
Es gab diverse URLs, wo man das machen konnte.
Es gab vor allem dann noch einen zweiten Hack, der danach kam, dass der dir von dem nur jetzt redet. Das war dann sozusagen, da haben sie es irgendwie geschafft JavaScripts zu embedden, was dann bei dir angezeigt wird. Genau, und dann haben sie irgendwie das Passwort abgefangen.
Die DNS-Files, die kann man über mydns.com auch sehr leicht ändern.
Ja, aber nur eigene.
Nee, nicht nur eigene. Wenn man sich da ein bisschen auskennt, kann man auch andere ändern.
Ja, aber nur die von Leuten, die da registriert sind. Also ich bezweifle, dass du meine DNS-Einträge ändern kannst.
Na, möglich wär das schon.
Also garantiert.
Aber nicht über mydns.com.
Mein DNS-Com, das die Kinder heutzutage so kennen.
Ich meine webbasierte Meldienste sind eigentlich keine schlechte Idee.
Eigentlich ist es eine sinnvolle Sache.
Eigentlich ist es eine tolle Sache.
Die Implementierung halt.
Die Leute machen es nicht freiwillig, wie sie wollen, damit Geld für ihn.
Also wenn jemand eine gute Idee hat und einen Service anbietet, der mir was nützt, dann lese ich da oben auch mal einen Banner von mir aus. Ich muss eigentlich draufklicken.
Das ist okay, aber dass sie deine Adresse weitergeben? Okay, das ist eine arme Geschichte. Das ist eine ungeschraubt, das passiert, aber kann man eigentlich von außen...
Wobei es webbasierte Mail gibt, wo speziell angegeben wird, dass sie das angeblich nicht tun. Also das ist nicht um Mailing, das geht sondern tatsächlich nur um die Werbung auf der Seite.
Aber ja.
Das ist das sogenannte Privacy Statement.
Also ich denke, dass man da in den nächsten Jahren sowieso überhaupt nicht mehr drum rumkommen wird, weil sich plötzlich dieses Netz finanzieren muss in irgendeiner Form. Und ich glaube, da wird man um Mailinglisten und um Adress-Sammlungen und so einfach nicht mehr drum rumkommen. Man braucht einfach mehrere E-Mail-Adressen. Nämlich eine, die zum Surfen, wo man in die Mail checkt sozusagen. Und dann eine für Kommunikation.
Und man braucht eigentlich noch 10 andere auch, so wie man auch unterschiedliche Telefonnummern haben möchte zu Hause. Eine fürs Bad. Eine fürs Schlafzimmer. Eine, wo es über Eilklingeln.
Und eine auf Nachtschaltung.
Ich will eigentlich eher unterschiedliche Nummern für bestimmte Tageszeiten.
Auch das ist möglich.
Das ist einfach nur drei, vier Leute, die mich nach 22 Uhr anrufen dürfen. Anmailen dürfen.
Wir haben jetzt leider zwischen 22 und 3 Uhr eingegangen.
Du hast auch noch eine hübsche Geschäftsidee in Anrufbeantworter für E-Mail-Boxen.
Gibt's doch, heißt Vacation.
Hast du einfach einen Autoresponder oder was?
Genau, ich bin im Urlaub.
Ich bin im Urlaub, genau.
Das ist immer sehr lustig, weil Leute, die in Medinglisten eingefahren sind. Du schickst mir einen Chaosradio-Ticker raus und dann krieg ich dreißigmal den Hinweis, dass irgendwie der Teilnehmer gerade im Urlaub ist oder irgendwie sein Handy nicht eingeschaltet.
Hier sind noch Anrufe. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio.
Ich hab ne Frage zu Newsgroups. Und zwar, ich hab mir das gerade mal so runtergeladen, also bei der TU Cottbus, welche Newsgroups alles gibt. Das sind irgendwie 12.000 oder so. Und ich weiß nicht, welche werden da überhaupt ausgewählt, dass sie dann auf dem Newsgroup-Turbo da rumliegen.
Das macht der Provider, also der kann eigentlich sagen, alles was mit Sex zu tun hat, will ich nicht haben.
Alles was jetzt drin steht will ich nicht haben.
Weißt du, der sucht das einfach so aus, also von allen Newsgroups, die es gibt oder so.
Meinst du jetzt du oder die Uni zum Beispiel?
Du meinst, wonach dein Provider auswählt, welche Gruppen es überhaupt gibt.
Ja genau.
Jede Newsgroup fängt irgendwann mal irgendwo an zu existieren und verteilt sich dann über alle miteinander verbundenen News Server. Die großen Provider hängen eigentlich auch alle an großen News Server ran und ein guter Provider holt sich eigentlich auch alle News Groups. Es mag News Groups geben, die nur in bestimmten Servernetzen verfügbar sind.
Die nur lokal sind.
Die du für den speziellen News Server fragen musst, um die zu bekommen. Aber das ist die Ausnahme. Also alle News Groups, über die man so redet, die kriegst du eigentlich auch bei jedem Provider. Und wenn nicht, dann ist dein Provider scheiße.
Was kriegst du denn? Also dieses Best-of-Internet, finde ich da zum Beispiel auch. Also das gibt's da auch.
Also ich glaube, bei den Unis hast du wenig Probleme. Ich meine 12.000 klingt schon nach einem guten Schnitt.
Ja, der hat auch ganz schön lang geladen.
Ja, das sind wahrscheinlich alle drin, die dich wirklich interessieren.
Ja, es gibt ja noch so eine Zusatz-Newsclub von wegen, weil ich hier so einem Kabelmodem dran hänge. Und die haben halt ein spezielles Ding. Aber ich glaube, da kommt man halt nur rein, wenn man auch ein Kabelmodem hat oder so. Und hier an dem Zusatzprovider hängt sozusagen.
Ach so, so was gibt's natürlich, klar. Was heißt denn Kabelmodem? Das heißt über Fernsehkabel?
Über Fernsehkabel, ja.
Wie schnell wirst denn da?
Also das ist runter gebremst, irgendwie per Software auf zweifach ISDN. Aber ich hab, also in der Testphase hat's 10 Megabit gemacht. Das ist, nennt sich Incarnet. Also das ist irgendwie AVC, Antennen verschrieb HotBus, die dann den Anschluss machen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es dir was geholfen hilft. Es gibt's halt nur in Wohnheimen.
Ach so, die Wohnhäume sind damit angebunden? Das geht dann direkt aber zur Uni? Also die Uni ist sozusagen der Provider?
Ja, das ist etwas kompliziert. Das Mail läuft irgendwie zum Teil anders. Das ist also super kompliziert. Mit irgendwelchen Proxys noch dazwischen. Für HTTP, aber für anderen Kram nicht. Wo man sich dann irgendwie am Anfang mal einloggen muss. Das ist praktisch so, wenn ich einen Rechner anstelle, dann bin ich immer automatisch im Internet.
Hast du mal einen TraceRoute gemacht? Dann such mal einen TraceRoute Programm. Dann machst du TraceRoute nach www.apple.com und dann siehst du, wo deine Pakete langgehen. Und dann siehst du halt auch, wo deine Pakete zuerst landen. Ob die durch die TU Cottbus durchmarschieren oder sonst wo. Aber das Letzte ist auch nicht so wichtig. Das funktioniert, das ist prima.
Ja, es hat etwas gedauert, aber jetzt läuft der Rinsekram.
In jeder Raum hat es irgendwie 128 Kilobit oder das ganze Wohnheim?
Ne, es ist so, dass man sich das Modem mieten muss.
Warum sind die runtergedrosselt?
Das hängt am Tarif. Also ich muss jetzt 30 Mark am Monat dafür abbrücken, dass ich das Modem kriege und halt diesen Zugang mit 128 Kilobit. Günstig. Und die anderen Leute, 50 Mark kriegt man 2 Megabit und für 80.
Und der Traffic ist kostenfrei.
Zahlst du noch was dazu für die übertragenden Daten?
Ne, gar nichts. Also es war am Anfang ein Gespräch, aber es ist nichts dergleich.
Wenn ihr jetzt nach der Sendung 2 Autos sehr schnell nach Cottus fahren seht, dann sitzt in dem einen der Chaos Computer Club.
Das ist gut zu wissen. Das braucht man einfach überall. Das ist das, was man haben will. Aber man ist jetzt einen Schritt weiter in Berlin. Demnächst gibt es einen Provider, der Telefongespräche in seinem Netz kostenlos vermittelt.
Also so flat rate mäßig.
Genau, das ist aber erstmal nur Telefon. Dann muss man mal gucken, welche Internetprovider da hinterher kommen.
Das Problem habe ich zum Glück nicht mehr.
Das ist wohl wahr, ja.
Na cool, ist deine Frage denn beantwortet worden?
Ja, die ist beantwortet.
Das ist doch super.
Hey, wir blicken mit Neid zu dir hinauf und sagen Tschüss. Da kosten wir 10 Megabit wahrscheinlich 100 Mark.
Die brauche ich gar nicht. Noch mal sehen.
Also ich kann mich an CDs erinnern, wo Star Wars drauf stand. Ich meine, da bin ich schon ganz praktisch gewesen.
Weißt du, wo die dran hängen, was das für ein Provider ist?
Die Uni selber, also die ist sehr schlecht angebunden, glaube ich.
Also ist man dann an die Uni angebunden mit diesem System?
Ja, an der Uni und an Krockbuss selber ist aber auch nicht so direkt am DFM, sondern geht noch irgendwie auf Frankfurt oder sonst was, habe ich mal gehört. Oder aus Kenna bin ich nicht, ich habe das selber leider nicht. Oder mich. Ja, mich hat das Thema News Groups ein bisschen weiter interessiert. Wie haltet ihr das, wie das im Moment so technisch gelöst ist? Wie die Zukunft so weiter läuft? So gerade Sachen wie Spam in News Groups und dass die Artikel nicht gerade immer zum Thema gehören. Ob das irgendwie technisch noch weiterentwickelt werden müsste, dass das irgendwie anders läuft?
Ich glaube technisch ist das Quatsch. Ich glaube da wird eher wieder, es gibt ja auch moderierte News Groups. Ich denke das wird eher auf so einer pro forma Registrierung oder so.
Also ich meine, gegen Spam lässt sich mit irgendwie News Authentication und so, lässt sich schon noch ein bisschen was drehen. Also man kann auch News Server so betreiben, dass man sich da einloggen muss. Das werden sicherlich in Zukunft mehr Provider so benutzen. Wenn die Nachfrage nach News auch ein bisschen gestiegen ist, ist es derzeit bei denen noch nicht so richtig in der Zielscheibe. Aber das wird schon noch kommen, weil News wird nicht aussterben und wird sicherlich weiter anwachsen.
Ich meine eben dieses NNTP ist eben ewig alt und wenn man das jetzt neu machen würde, würde man wahrscheinlich etliches anders machen.
Hast du da Ideen?
Nein, ich bin leider nicht so der Ausgänger. Deswegen frage ich ja euch, ob es da irgendwie Ideen gibt, in welcher Richtung die liegen oder so. Weil vom Prinzip her, von der Philosophie ist, sind diese News einfach unübertrefflich von der Kommunikation.
Na deswegen wird sich das einfach so weiterentwickeln, wie sie es bisher auch entwickelt hat, nämlich sehr langsam über einen sehr langen Zeitraum. Das ist jetzt irgendwie auch 20 Jahre alt und hat seine Struktur weitgehend unverändert beibehalten. Und das bedeutet, dass es ein sehr überlebensfähiges Protokoll ist im Internet. Sonst wäre es schon längst ausgestorben.
Ja, aber es gibt auch genauso Überlegungen, die dann Internet 2 heißen, wo alles neu wieder modelliert wird sozusagen. Genauso könnte man sich auch mal News 2 ausdenken, ob das dann vielleicht mal alles neu und alles gut wird.
Naja, die Frage ist, ob dort erst mal komplett alle Protokolle neu entwickelt werden, ob man nicht einfach beginnt mit einer geschlossenen Benutzergruppe, mit schnelleren Leitungen, das zu machen, was man bisher auch schon gemacht hat.
Ja, und außerdem lässt sich das mit dem Spam ja auch nur verhindern, wenn man weiß, wer das geschickt hat und das führt wiederum dazu, dass einfach die Anonymität flöten geht. Und ob das gewollt ist, ist ja auch noch die Frage.
Oder ein zweites, genau, ein nicht anonymes Usenet.
Ja, das ist die Frage, die da russisch wird.
Dass vielleicht Leute, denen das reicht, aber dafür eine sinnvolle Kommunikation haben wollen, mir wäre das zum Beispiel lieber.
Ich glaube, das nennt sich mehr die Liste.
Das wär dir lieber, wenn alle Berliner Clubs nachts erstmal deinen Personalausweis sehen wollen, bevor du in einer Party teilnehmen kannst.
Naja, deswegen kann man nicht in allen Zellen stören. Also manchmal denke ich mir, wenn ich bei DE. Org, CCC, hier mir dann mal gucke, was da drin ist, da überlege ich mir schon, ob das so mir gefällt.
Also ich glaube, wir müssen uns daran gewöhnen, dass das alles schlechter wird. Das Internet ist halt nicht mehr ein Kreis von akademischen Hippie-Kindern, sondern es ist mittlerweile so ein Abbild der Gesellschaft geworden. Idioten gibt es heute überall.
Die kriegst du ja nicht raus, auch nicht aus Dior CCC.
Das gehört einfach dazu. Ich denke, es ist sehr viel notwendiger, dass man selber eine gewisse Medienkompetenz entwickelt, so wie man bei einer Zeitung weiß, dass man ab einer bestimmten Buchstabengröße weniger glaubt. So muss man eben auch bei News die Anzahl der Dollar-Zeichen in der Mail dem Inhalt vergleichen.
Bei einem selbst, das vielleicht weniger das Problem ist, eher bei den Krawattentypen das Problem, denen das beizubringen.
Das ist ein Kommunikationsproblem und das ist ja im richtigen Leben auch nicht anders.
Man redet ja von Zeit zu Zeit auch einfach mal aneinander vorbei.
Auf dem Internet tun das halt sehr viele Leute sehr häufig.
Ich finde übrigens, Wahrheit im Netz ist ein schönes Thema für eine Sendung.
Ja und da fiel mir gerade wieder ein, ihr hattet doch früher mal Chaosradio-Kurzmeldungen. Meinst du, so was mal wieder machen könntet?
Ja, gerne.
Dann eine andere von mir schon mehrmals wiederholte Bitte war mal die Webcam beim Chaosradio.
Ja, unbedingt.
Hier gibt es aber kein Internet.
So lange es hier noch nicht mal Internet-Ports für die Laptops gibt.
Bei mir läuft alles.
Ich hab hier gerade lauter Webcams.
4 Stücke.
Webcam ist durchaus eine Idee, wobei im Moment wäre es ziemlich langweilig.
Wenn ihr uns sehen könnt, glaubt ihr uns doch nicht mehr.
Du stellst dir vor, dass hier lauter junge, dynamische, gut gebaute Männer sitzen, aber es ist ganz anders. Webcam haben wir natürlich auch schon drüber nachgedacht. Zerbights, wir kommen bald ins Jahr 2000.
Wir müssen auch über Internet nachdenken.
Ansonsten schön auf dich, Johnny, wieder zu hören an in Chaosradio.
Danke. Tschüss, schönen Abend. Ihr hört Chaosradio. Wir suchen zwei große Wohnungen in Kostbus.
In der Nähe des Studentenwohnheims. In Isariskaw Reichweite.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio. Wer ist da? Ich hab irgendwie mit dieser rechten Menüleiste hier... Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio.
Hallo?
Junge dynamische Männer sitzen vorm Computer.
Sag mal, willst du dich anrufen, wenn Jürgen dran ist am Dienstag?
Es wird so, die haben ihre Stimmmänner verschenkt.
Die brauchen sie nicht mehr.
Ja, ich sag dir schonmal Tschüss, ja? Fällt gerade auf, wie lange ich nicht mehr hier war.
Ja hallo, hier ist Felix.
Hallo Felix.
Also erstens zum Thema Wahrheit. Ja, also ich bin ein gut aussehender, jung, dynamischer Mann.
Alles klar.
Thema Fritz und Internet. Also ich hab letztens was runtergeladen mit 178K. Ich war schwer begeistert. Konstant über eine Viertelstunde.
Wie als Mail oder was?
Nö, von eurem, na hier...
Genau, hier...
Die gingen sehr gut und sehr schnell. Und jetzt die eigentliche Frage zum Thema, die Rute. Ich kriege gelegentlich in regelmäßigen Abständen E-Mails, die nicht an mich gerichtet sind. Also weder vom Absender, den kenn ich noch, noch den Adressaten. Und ich steh auch sonst nicht im Header drinnen. Wie passiert sowas?
Gute Frage.
Ich selber bin nicht adressiert.
Ja, das ist eine Blind Carbon Copy. Damit wird nirgends in der Mail erwähnt, dass dieser Durchschlag existiert. Du bekommst ihn aber.
Das steht auch in deiner Kopie nicht da drinnen, dass die auch für dich gedacht haben.
Aber es steht, also der Webserver, der Mail Server, der die Mail für dich annimmt, der kriegt schon die Adresse gesagt. Die schreibt er aber nicht unbedingt in die Mail mit rein.
Ich hab auch schon Mails gekriegt, die definitiv in eine private Kommunikation waren. Also von Horst-Ed, irgendwo.de, an Martina-Ed, irgendwo.de. Und hallo Martina, wie geht's? Ich bin im Urlaub, tschüss Horst.
Das ist das, was wir meinten, als wir vorhin sagten, dass e-Mail total unsicher ist. Und dass überall möglich ist, dass Kopien entstehen. Wenn sie nicht absichtlich gemacht sind, dann sind sie unter Umständen unabsichtlich geschehen, weil die Software nicht funktioniert oder irgendwas schlecht konfiguriert ist. Das ist eben genau der Punkt. Man weiß überhaupt nicht, ob die Mail, die man schickt, ankommt. Ob sie einmal ankommt, mehrere Male ankommt und bei wie vielen Leuten sie ein oder mehrere Male ankommt.
Und besteht irgendwie die Möglichkeit, dass man so ein Blind-Copy doch noch rauskriegt, wenn man sie immer richtig aufmacht?
Wo? Dein Receiving MTA, also der, der für dich die Mail annimmt, der weiß, an wen sie geht, weil der packt sie in deine Mailbox rein. Der schreibt das aber nicht unbedingt in die Mail rein. Es gibt MTAs, die tun das. Und es gibt auch Konfigurationen für andere MTAs, die das noch nicht tun, dass sie das dann tun. Und dann musst du dir die Received Headers genauer angucken. Oder bei QMail ist es so, dass du einen Delivered To-Header hast. Und da steht der Envelope To, sag ich jetzt mal, also das ist der Briefumschlag sozusagen, das ist das, was ausgetauscht wird, während die Mail sozusagen an deinen SMTP-Server ausgeliefert wird.
Aber wie kommt denn da ran?
Man muss es entweder selber konfigurieren, wenn man das...
Da hat er wahrscheinlich keinen Zugriff drauf.
Genau, dann müsstest du deinen Provider darum bitten. Vielleicht hat er es auch schon getan. Guck dir mal die Header-Zeilen genau an.
Also kann sein, dann steht manchmal so was drin wie Apparently 2 oder...
Ja, so was zum Beispiel.
Manche schreiben es doch in der Recife-Zeile rein. Apparently 2 ist ein Header, der vom MTA eingesetzt wird, wenn kein Adressat aus den vorgegebenen Headern hervorgeht. Also sonst wird dann der Envelope 2.
Das ist aber mit einem Gesichtsausdruck, der doch eher gelangweilt ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das mit der Webcam eine gute Idee ist.
So wie Tim gerade Verstehe gesagt hat. Naja, die Übertragungen sind ja noch nicht so gut zu fahren.
War das eine zu technische Antwort? Oder war das das, was du gesagt hast?
Ja, ich meine nicht unbedingt damit, dass ich das nicht anfangen kann, da ich meinen Provider nicht erreiche, aber ansonsten danke.
Du erreichst den nicht?
Die bitte?
Du erreichst deinen Provider nicht?
Na doch, ich erreiche den schon, aber ich werde ihn nicht dazu bringen, das System nochmal neu umzustellen, der ist vor, dass es gerade läuft.
Dann natürlich mal dringend den Provider wechseln.
Genau.
Aber der ist kostenlos.
Ah, hat er gerade.
Du wahrscheinlich zahlst auch nur 670 Mark für irgendwie 1000 Megabit.
Ach nee, stink normales 333er Modem über die Uni und so.
Jo, hallo. Hi, wer bist denn du? Hier ist Chaosradio. Ja, das kann aus ganz bestimmten Gründen definitiv nicht sein.
Auf die Anrufe kommt nicht unbedingt immer da an, wo sie kommen sollen.
Vielleicht hoffen wir halt einmal.
Ach, da war wieder mein Vater dran. Das wäre erstaunlich, wenn er da dran wäre. Es wäre sehr spannend mit ihm zu reden jetzt. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio.
Den wollte er auch nicht mit uns hören.
Ah, siehst du, es ist nach zwölf.
Die Bekloppen sind aufgewacht.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio. Wer ist denn da? Hallo Stefan.
Und zwar schon mal eine Frage. Gibt es irgendein Programm für Windows, mit dem man seinen Header noch nachträglich oder seinen Header verändern kann? Weil ich habe jetzt eine E-Mail von meinem Bruder bekommen und der hat dort in seinem Header sein, was ich pgp key und sowas reingeschrieben. Dass man das auch in Windows irgendwie noch ändern kann?
Na ja, das kommt mal drauf an. Du kannst natürlich lokal einen MTA aufsetzen. Also ein Programm, was als MTA fungiert oder ein MTA. Dann müsstest du deinen Made User Agent dazu konfigurieren, über den localhost auszusenden. Und dann ist es natürlich in deiner Macht, die einfach mal zu verändern.
Oder du kannst auch Headerzahlen hinzufügen, die die gängigen Mailer bieten, Möglichkeiten Headerzahlen hinzuzufügen. Und da hat er wahrscheinlich seinen Fingerprint wohl eher hinzugefügt, nicht seinen Key, oder?
Ja, er hat irgendwie so ein X.
X-Fingerprint, da.
Ja genau, X-Pgp, sowas.
Was für einen kleinen verwendest du denn?
Ähm, zur Zeit melde ich über Netscape. Fortagent habe ich auch, also wechselt sich. Bei Netscape geht das.
Kann man neue Header hinzufügen, oder was?
X-Headers kann man bestimmt hinzufügen.
Du kannst die Livery einfach verzögern, das heißt du kannst sagen, er soll die Mail nicht sofort ausschicken, sondern erst später. Das ist in dem Fall nützlich, wenn du offline bist, aber das gibt dir auch die Möglichkeit, die von Netscape auf die Platte geschriebenen Files nachträglich zu verändern.
Aber komfortabel ist das nicht.
Was möchtest du machen? Du möchtest auch gerne so ein Fingerprint in deinem Header haben. Ist das richtig? Na, dann musst du einfach mal über Netscape, ich weiß nicht, ob man da zusätzliche Header eintragen kann bei Netscape. Du musst, kann man nicht...
Die Livery verzögern, wenn man sie auf Platte schreibt, und dann kannst du das freie editieren.
Also Eudora kann das auf jeden Fall. Eudora ist noch so relativ oldschool dafür, dass es ein GUI-Programm ist. Also das ist so der Mailer, der glaube ich noch ein bisschen am nächsten dran ist an der reinen, roten Internetmail, der noch nicht so viel bunt drumherum macht. Den gibt es auch irgendwie in einer Lite-Version für irgendwie kostenlos.
Ja, das Qualcomm ist der, das also...
Es geht auch eben wie Eudora-Pumpe.
Na stimmt, das Eudora geht auch, ne? Guter Klein, finde ich.
Okay, geholfen.
Ich guck gerade hier in Netscape ein bisschen rum, aber ich glaube nicht, dass man da einen Header editieren kann.
Noch was anderes. Dieser Message-ID, was heißt die für eine Bedeutung? In der Newsgroup haben sie mich dauernd genervt. Ich sollte die in meinem Forward-Agent umstellen, dass die nicht automatisch irgendwie generiert wird.
Bei Newsgroups kann ich nicht so viel zu sagen, aber bei Mail ist es so, dass die Mail eindeutig einem Rechner zuzuordnen ist. Das heißt, das ist ja irgendwie eine Zahl und ein String.
Nicht, dass sie einem Rechner zuzuordnen, sondern die Message-ID ist ein String, der so zusammengesetzt ist, dass er auf jeden Fall eindeutig ist. Wenn da dein eigener Computer, deine Uhrzeit und noch eine Zufallszahl drin ist, dann ist es absolut auszuschließen, dass irgendein anderer Computer diese gleiche Message-ID generiert. Das brauchst du eigentlich auch bei Mail. Nicht alle Mailer machen das, eine Message-ID zu generieren. Bei News ist es aber bitter nötig, da braucht man das einfach generell. Da wird das immer generiert. Wenn dir jemand gesagt hat, der soll nicht automatisch generiert werden, dann hat er gesagt, Internet soll nicht so funktionieren, wie es funktionieren soll. Aber vielleicht war mit deiner Message-ID irgendwas falsch.
Ja, da gibt es eine Option in der Ford-Agent-Einstellung, dass irgendwie die Message-ID von meinem Provado kommt und nicht das Ford-Agent, das dir einträgt.
Und dein Provado trägt sie dann nicht ein?
Nein, der trägt dann andere ein. Also der trägt dann die richtige ein. Und Ford-Agent schreibt eine andere drüber und dann... Es gibt dann mehrere? Nein, es gibt nur eine. Oder?
Ja, es sollte nur eine geben, weil es ist ja eine ID.
Und Ford-Agent schreibt eine rein und dann ändert mein Provado nichts um. Wenn ich das aber ausschalte im Ford-Agent, dann schreibt mein Provado die richtige rein.
Was heißt die richtige? Der schreibt dann auch eine rein? Also der schreibt dann eine rein. Und was genau war jetzt das Problem?
Ich wollte eigentlich nur wissen, was diese Message-ID bedeutet.
Ja, die ist zur Identifikation dieser Mail gut. Zum Beispiel kann man da anhand der ID feststellen, ob jemand eine Mail wirklich mehrmals verschickt hat oder ob sie sich auf dem Weg verdoppelt wurde.
Und News-Server zum Beispiel, die untereinander News austauschen und jeder schickt jedem das, was er hat, identifizieren die einzelnen Postings nach dieser Message-ID. Das heißt, die tauschen im Prinzip, fragen sie sich die ganze Zeit, Message-ID, hast du die schon, hast du die schon? Nee, kann ich nicht. So ein bisschen wie mit diesem Bildchen sammeln. Weißt du, in diesem komischen Panini auf Keyboard für Kinder und so.
Hammer, Hammer, Hammer, Hammer.
Nicht Hammer, nicht Hammer, nicht Hammer.
Ja, so ist das mit der Message-ID. Also man müsste sich die jetzt mal genau angucken, um zu sagen, was da jetzt konkret braun ist. Das ist mir noch ein bisschen schleierhaft, aber sie ist halt dazu da, um deine Nachricht eindeutig identifizierbar zu machen. Viele Leute benutzen die auch, um auf andere Postings hinzuweisen, wie schon in Message-ID gesagt wurde. Tralala. Normalerweise macht das dein News Agent, also dein News Programm auch schon automatisch. Der News Leader. Das hat deine Frage vielleicht beantwortet. Ja, das mit diesem CCC und dem BCC. Hier ist Chaosradio, wer ist denn da?
Hier ist Uwe aus Berlin. Ich hab ein Problem mit dem kleinen Xion. Ich weiß nicht, ob euch einer davon auskennt.
Mit deiner Mail?
Mit dem alten oder dem neuen?
Eher mit dem neuen. Das Problem ist, einfach eine Connection zu kriegen mit einem Mail-Server.
Was benutzen für ein Programm, für ein Email-Reader?
Das eingebaute Email, also diese Message-Reader, und die Sache klappt auch teilweise, aber nicht immer. Also zum Beispiel Yahoo geht gar nicht, da wird der Pop-Server gar nicht gefunden, oder geht der Login gar nicht. Und mit GMX kann ich zwar Empfang, aber nicht senden. Und mit Berlin.de kann ich auch senden.
Wenn du nicht senden kannst, könnte es daran liegen, bei GMX war das glaube ich so, dass du erst mal kurz deine Mail abholen musst, oder gucken musst, ob welche da ist.
Wegen dem Zeitfenster, ne?
Genau, denn es gibt keine Authentifizierung für ausgehende Mail.
Noch nicht.
Na, das Problem ist ja, wenn du zuerst versuchst zu senden und dann erst abrufst, dann erlaubt er das nicht. Einfach aus dem Grund, dass er nicht wissen kann, dass du berechtigt bist Mail zu schicken. Umgegen, wenn du sie zuerst holst, dann ist deine IP-Adresse gekennzeichnet für ein Zeitfenster, in dem du berechtigt bist zu senden.
Hab ich probiert, geht aber auch nicht. Der bricht, also dann kommt im Ziel ein unbekannter Fehler. Und bei Yahoo zum Beispiel, wenn ich da den Server anwille, der auch von Yahoo angegeben ist, allerdings Yahoo Kommus, also Amerika oder so, dann kommt entweder Username falsch oder Canvas falsch oder Server spärt. Das ist die gleiche Meldung, die ich kriege, wenn ich versuche, über GMX mit meinem User-Account reinzugehen, anstelle von der Kundennummer.
Du verwendest aber jeweils den gültigen Account für den jeweils letzten Server.
Bei Yahoo ist es eine E-Mail-Adresse, da sind die Vorgaben auch komplett richtig, er nimmt es nicht an. Bei GMX klappt die Vorgabe erst recht nicht, nur über die Kundennummer. Zum Glück hat GMX eine Kundennummer. Mit dem Name at gmx.de komme ich auch nicht rein, nur über die Kundennummer zum Beispiel. Also muss da irgendein Problem mit dieser blöden Software von dem Xeon sein? GMX verweist dann wieder auf das Handynetz, also in dem Fall auf E+, und E+, gibt an, dass es gibt einen Server, der da wohl heißt mail.de.uh.net, über den würde es auch gehen, aber da klappt es genauso wenig. Also niemand weiß irgendwo ansatzweise eine Hilfe im Grunde genommen.
Du hast ein Xeon an deinem E-Plus-Handy?
Wie meinste das jetzt? Über das F25.
Ah, darüber machst du Internet.
Über Infrarot?
Und, ähm, ohje, das ist aber nicht schnell.
Na gut, ein 960er-Handy geht eh nicht schnell über Handy zurzeit. Ja, ist klar, aber fürs Email reicht es doch erst mal. Ja, natürlich. Aber wie gesagt, die Connections aufzubauen, ja, geht überhaupt nicht, der Bericht da jedes Mal ab, von wegen Kennwort oder Username sei falsch. Und bei GMX kann ich empfangen, ich hab's auch probiert über dieses Zeitfenster, aber selbst da kommt unbekannter Fehler. Das einzige, wo geht, ist Berlin.de. Da kann ich sie regelmäßig senden und empfangen. Das Berlin.de ist so nett, die geben dir gleich den vollen Vor- und Zunahmen als E-Mail-Adresse anstatt von einer Alias.
Also ich meine, wenn es mit Berlin.de geht, dann kannst du davon ausgehen, dass deine Software funktioniert. Und dass die Probleme, die du bei den anderen Providern hast, einfach mit der Konfiguration zu tun haben. Also musst du dir die 5x angucken.
Kann das mit irgendwelchen Port-Adressen zusammenhängen?
Port-Adressen?
Na ja, es ist doch immer 110 für Pop.
Richtig, und 25 für den anderen.
Kannst du den noch einstellen? Aha, naja, den würde ich mal nicht ändern.
Und was ist dieses Mime-Coding? Hat das was zu sagen?
Das hat mit dem Versenden erstmal nichts zu tun. Nee.
Ich hab nochmal ein Hinweis bekommen, dass zum Beispiel einige E-Mail-Programme nicht dieses App-Zeichen erlauben bei diesem Einloggen, aber einige Server, dass sie dieses App-Zeichen haben wollen.
Das kann schon sein.
Ein E-Mail-Programm, das von einem App-Zeichen erlauben zu kosten, ist kein E-Mail-Programm.
Man kann nichts ausschließen, ich meine.
Also Programme können definitiv...
Nein, als Username. Dass wir einen Username haben wollen, xy.yahoo. Aber andererseits, dass das App-Zeichen keine...
Hast du denn als Login-Namen dein sowieso addyahoo.com eingegeben?
Eigentlich nicht, weil so wird es von mir nicht verlangt. Wenn ich jetzt online per Internet mich in Yahoo einlogge, dann gebe ich ja nur ein xy und mein Passwort. Dann gebe ich ja nicht mein echtes und meinen echten Namen an. Und genauso habe ich auch, als ich dieses E-Mail-Forwarding eingerichtet habe über einen Pop-Server, habe ich auch die ganzen Daten bekommen, gebe einen dein Username, dein User-ID und einfach nur das Passwort ohne irgendwie addyahoo.com oder so ähnlich. Also ich soll es nicht machen. Aber andererseits, GMX zum Beispiel, die willst du haben, die wollen mit add.com, also add sowieso haben.
Naja, offensichtlich machen das alle unterschiedlich und wir benutzen das nicht. Und deshalb kennen wir uns damit auch nicht so gut aus.
Gut, kann man dann eine letzte Frage haben, die ein Leben so macht. Kennt einer von euch einen Tipp für einen Berliner Provider, wo man kostenlos Internet nutzen kann?
Kostenlos Internet nutzen?
Nein.
Ja, aber wir sagen es nicht. Nein, nur mit Telefongebühren, wo die Internetgebühren drin sind, da gibt es ja wirklich Anzeigen bis zum Abwinken von den ganzen Telefongesellschaften.
Es gibt keinen kostenlosen Internetprovider. Das war vorweg. Sie kosten alle Geld und mehr oder weniger das Gleiche. Und manche kosten zu viel und die anderen kosten auch zu viel. Und andere Provider gibt es derzeit noch nicht. Und man muss mal gucken.
Germanynet wäre eine Alternative in der Form.
Nein. Du zahlst immer Telefon.
Ja, das ist ja in Ordnung. Telefon zahle ich ja gerne, aber es geht um diesen monatlichen Beitrag.
Telefon ist doch viel mehr als dieser monatliche Beitrag. Du telefonierst doch irgendwie 100 Mark.
Aber nicht für eine E-Mail-Adresse. So mit E-Mails. Dafür brauche ich keinen Internet-Account.
Na ja, das ist vielleicht wahr. Na ja gut, wenn dir die paar Mark noch so viel ausmachen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wo du...
Ich meine, ich seh nicht einen jetzt mit einem Internet-Account von 8 oder 9 Mark einzurichten, nur für E-Mails aufzutauschen, im Grunde genommen.
Dann können wir dir wohl nicht weiterhelfen.
Noch eine Frage an Johnny. Hat er noch seinen Palm? Welcher ist denn noch, der Palm Professional oder schon neuer?
Nee, ich hab einen 5er.
Einen 5er mittlerweile?
Aber ich hab noch keine Mail darüber abgerufen, aber mit dem 3er immer, und das ging wunderbar.
Also hat er schon vorher auch einen anderen Palm gehabt?
Genau.
Und den hast du bei mir gekauft?
Ich hab dadurch jeden...
Ach, den hast du bei dir gekauft?
Ich glaub, ich hab inzwischen jeden Handheld der Welt gehabt.
Handheld?
Nee, um Gottes Willen, die fahr sie nicht an. Also die fass ich zwar an, aber die sind mir echt zu langsam.
Obwohl der Casio Pire, der neue, ist ganz in Ordnung.
Den wollt ich mir mal angucken, wegen MP3-Möglichkeiten.
Wie war dein Name nochmal?
Die stürzen schon im Kaufhaus immer ab, wenn man die anfässt.
Toll.
Ach guck ich mir doch mal an.
Jetzt sind das wahrscheinlich Crash.
Content, gleich gibt's Content.
Wir können ja auch mal wieder was erzählen.
Nee, kurz in vor gibt's jetzt Content.
Ah, der dritte Versuch hier zum Lachen zu rufen.
In Fritz rund um Cottbus, dann 103, 2.
Null Uhr 31.
Konfrontation. Zum ersten Mal seit Beginn der Demonstrationen in Belgrad ist es am Abend zu Zusammenstößen mit der Polizei gekommen. Mit Wasserwerfern und Schlagstöcken wurden rund 25.000 Demonstranten an einem Protestmarsch zum Wohnhaus des jugoslawischen Präsident Milošević gehindert. Aufschub. Die Bundesregierung hat heute ihren Beschluss vertagt, 100 deutsche Sanitätssoldaten nach Osttimor zu schicken. Zum einen ist die Truppenentsendung in der Koalition umstritten, zum anderen ist die Finanzierung noch unklar. Stellungnahmen. Die Landesvorstände von SPD und CDU in Brandenburg haben am Abend den Koalitionsvertrag gebilligt. Sie empfahlen den Parteigremium dem Partei dem Papier zuzustimmen. Die bislang allein regierenden Sozialdemokraten stellen künftig fünf der Regierungspartner, vier Minister. Der CDU-Landesvorsitzende Schönbohm teilte mit, dass er Innenminister wird. Konflikt. Ein Einmarsch russischer Truppen in Tschechienien wird immer wahrscheinlicher. Nach einer Woche massiver Bomben, Angriffe auf Tschechienien ist ein erster Gesprächsversuch der russischen Regierung mit der Führung der abtrünnigen Kaukasusrepublik gescheitert.
Sport.
In der Fußball-Champions League spielten am Abend Borussia Dortmund beim norwegischen Vertreter Rosenbock Trondheim 2 zu 2. Bayer Leverkusen und Dynamo Kiew trennten sich 1 zu 1.
Wette.
Nachtzeit war es Regen um 12 Grad, am Tag bewölkt gelegentlich Regen, Tageshöchsttemperaturen 17 bis 20 Grad. Obwohl Fußball jetzt vorbei ist, endgültig gibt's immer noch keine Verkehrsfelder.
Naja, die mussten ja nicht nach Hause fahren.
Ja eben.
Fritz, kurz Info mit Falk Zilke.
So Kinder, ihr wisst ja, historische Ereignisse werfen immer ihre Schatten voraus. Ihr wisst aber auch, ich werfe zurück 7. und 8. Oktober 50 Jahre DDR. Schrecklich, schrecklich, schrecklich, überall werden FDR-Temparties stattfinden, dass man sich nur so ekelnd möchte. Was kann man dagegen tun? Man kann in die Volksbühne gehen. Da findet nämlich ein Video-Schnipsel-Spezialvortrag statt. Eine Indian-Party eigentlich unter der Überschrift Schlager. Am Ende des Ganges werden mit Indien und der DDR zwei dritte Weltländer im Schlager vergleiche Teste zusammen mit einem indischen Freund, Riyadh Vanir. Machen wir da einen prima Video-Schnipsel-Vortrag. Und danach gigantische Partys, eine großartige Bollywood-Film läuft im großen Haus, im Grünen Salon, New Asian Cool, Tanzerei im Roten Salon, indische Essen und sonst was. 7.8. Oktober ab 21 Uhr in der Volksbühne am Rosa-Luxemburg-Platz.
Halbe Stunde Chaosradio noch. Ich werde euch gleich erzählen, worüber wir reden. Und ihr könnt auch weiter anrufen. Zwei Leute liegen hier noch auf den Leitungen und viele rufen an. 031 für PostNAS 70, 97, 110. Das Chaosradio dreht sich heute um. Mit Themen E-Mail und Newsgroups. Auf Wiedersehen! Hab gerade wieder mal festgestellt, dass ich entschieden zu viel vor dem Computer sitze. Ich bin gerade kurz draußen gewesen, bin an Falk vorbeigegangen, der vor der Turnbandmaschine sitzt und die Fußballbeiträge zusammenschneidet, wahrscheinlich für den Frühmorgen früh oder heute früh und er wurde von Syr... Aber das ging mir zum ersten Mal mit dem Begriff Slip so, als ich dann an einen Übertragungsprotokoll gedacht hab und nicht...
Wofür steht Slip?
Das meint er.
Serial Line Internetprotokoll, IP über eine serielle Schnittstelle.
Das meint ich. Hier ist Chaosradio, hallo.
Hallo.
Neueste Nachricht über. Ich war so lange nicht mehr hier, dass ich sogar ihren Namen vergessen hab und bin darüber total froh. Wer bist denn du?
Ja, ich bin der Christian, hallo.
Hallo Christian.
Ja genau, und zwar hätt ich mal eine Frage. Und zwar, ich hab ein Problem mit einem Befehl und einer MS-Börseigenkörper-Aufforderung. Und zwar, wenn ich über, wenn ich das FDP denn eingebe online bin und nehme mal an, ich will auf einen FDP-Stocker oder so drauf. Und zwar, der Befehl geht bewirkt doch eigentlich, dass man, wenn man danach eben, was weiß ich, ein paar Zeichen ist und die Datei angibt, dass man die Datei downloadet. Und meine Frage ist dazu, wenn die gedownloadet wird, wo geht die Datei hin? Und wie kann ich die öffnen bzw. einlesen bzw.
auslesen?
Also, erstens ist das Thema heute an dich, melden.
Das kann man schnell erklären. Also, es gibt ein Kommando, das heißt lcd, localcd. Damit kannst du das Directory wählen, wohin das bei dir hinkopiert wird. Und get holt die Datei. Und dann liegt sie da. Und was du damit der Datei anfangen kannst, das hängt mal ganz von der Datei ab. Das kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Christian, schönen Abend.
Es gibt keine Poster.
Ja, weiß ich noch, dazu sagen wollte, also, meine Meinung jetzt über das Email-Scan oder so. Ich find's auch nicht irgendwie in Ordnung, aber... Also, meine Meinung wär auch...
Du hast nichts zu verbergen.
Nee, dass ich jetzt direkt per Telefon oder so schicken oder reden würde. Obwohl es da auch wieder einige Organisationen gibt, die...
Das ist auch wieder rar.
Wir können uns auch verstößt unterhalten.
Ich hab das nicht verstanden zum Schluss.
Das war ja auch verschlüsselt.
Nenn dich Deins.
Dein Wort war nicht sofort verstanden.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio.
Wahrscheinlich hat er doch verschlüsselt den Beitrag.
Ja, wer bist denn du?
Ja, also eigentlich wollte ich gerne mal zu dem Uwe sagen, der von anrufen hat. Der hat ja nachgefragt, wie das ist mit seinen E-Mails, weil er ja nur was, also kein Gold über uns zahlen wollte, um da seine E-Mails zu schicken. Und da wollte ich ihm einfach nur sagen, dass das ja wie beim normalen Telefonieren über dieses Call-by-Call-System auch über das Internet funktioniert. Also jetzt zum Beispiel bei Mobilecom oder Talknet.
Genau, richtig.
Also wenn er da einfach zum Beispiel die 0103net.de von Mobilecom und da kann er sich dann die DNS und so eine Scheiße runterladen und dann kann er sich das angucken und dann kann er sich das auf seinem, weiß nicht, was er auf dem Rechner hat, Unix oder so, kann er das dann einstellen.
Also ich weiß ja nicht, was er, wie er das macht.
Wie bitte?
Die machen Pop 3 und Webmail.
Ja, damit dann kann er sich das angucken und wenn er meint, dass ihn das für die Preise, also bei der SIG Mobilecom, zahlt man 3, 8 Stunden oder so, nur Telefongebühren, aber solange wird er nicht mailen. Und das wollte ich ihm eigentlich nur sagen und mit den E-Mails, was die Sicherheit anbelangt, ist, wie man jetzt gesehen hat, was bei Hotmail passiert ist, was die Schwede aus Schweden, wo das glaube ich ja herhackt, oder kam der herhackt, weiß ich nicht genau, aber ich glaube, das war Schweden und von diesem Hotmail-Script, den sie da bei Java-Script heruntergeladen haben, finde ich, also meiner Meinung ist, sag mal, dass das in Ordnung ist für die Leute, die das machen wollen. Sicherlich ist das scheiße, die Leute, die das dann betrifft. Ich persönlich würde es auch nicht sehr positiv finden, wenn meine E-Mails selbst veröffentlicht werden. Aber ich würde natürlich auch keine wichtigen Daten oder jetzt was super Persönliches über E-Mails schreiben, das ist ganz klar. Also wenn man sich ein bisschen damit auskennt, ist man ganz genau das. So eine E-Mail ist jederzeit und von jedem Anbieter equekt werden können.
So ist das.
Zur Sicherheit kommen wir gleich nochmal. Wir haben noch eine Fünsche, dann müssen wir jetzt kommen. Sicherheit, noch ein paar Sätze.
Erzähl doch mal.
Erzähl uns doch mal was über Anonymität, über Anonymerie-Mailer.
Los, mach mal.
Ja, wir hatten ja vorher schon mal die Diskussion zum Thema Anonymität oder inwieweit es möglich ist, Absender festzustellen, auch im Zusammenhang mit Spamern eben. Der Chaos Computer Club sieht sie natürlich primär mal die Aufgabe, irgendwie auch Datensicherheit und Datenschutz zu promoten. E-Mail ist ja grundsätzlich mal relativ leicht festzustellen, weil jeder beteiligte MTA im Regelfall auch Logfiles führt. Und an diesen Logfiles lässt sich ja sehen, wohin die Mail ging und woher die Mail kam. Ist auch nachträglich noch möglich. Und um diese Trafikanalysen zu verschleiern, gibt es Remail, also sogenannte pseudonyme Remailer, die wie ein Postfach funktionieren. Sie nehmen diese Post entgegen, nehmen jegliche Informationen aus, der sich auf die Herkunft der Mail schließen ließe, raus und leiten es an den Empfänger weiter.
Und dann hat man einen anonymen Mail empfangen.
Und verschickt.
Außer bei dem, der den Remailer betreibt.
Genau, man kann diese aber auch noch chainen. Es gibt die Möglichkeit, die in einer Kette zu betreiben. Das heißt, man hängt mehrere Remailer hintereinander. Sobald dein einziges Glied dieser Kette funktioniert, können die anderen Remailerbetreiber nichts mehr über die Herkunft des Autos und über das Ziel sagen.
Na, der erste über den Autor schon.
Na ja klar, aber wenn der erste kompromittiert ist und der Leit ist dann im zweiten weit und der zweite ist sicher, dann verliert der dritte ja die Autoinformation.
Und der erste kann die Mail auch am Schluss nicht mehr zuordnen an die empfangene Mail, also die irgendwo ankommt. Weil die natürlich verschlüsselt war vorher.
Achso, wenn du sie verschlüsselt an mehrere...
Genau, es wird für jeden Remailer einzeln verschlüsselt.
Das ist die einzige Möglichkeit, heutzutage noch halbwegs sicher Lösegeld einzuklappen.
Und die Mail muss dann aber in meinem Attachment haben, wo ein Gift drin ist, mit so zusammengesetzten Buchstaben. Jupp, jetzt wollte ich grad sagen, war die Frage damit beantwortet, aber es war gar keine Frage. Was für anonyme Remailer gibt es?
Na es gibt eine Übersicht über Remailer. Ein recht bekannter Remailer ist NymAliasnet. Von dem aber abzuraten, ist da relativ ungesichert, in einem Rechnerpool am MIT steht. Einfach mal ein Altar Vista plus Remailer eingeben plus List. Und es findet sich eine Liste von Remailern.
Gut, ansonsten Verschlüsselungen nochmal, ganz kurz angerissen.
Ja, da kann man ja gar nicht genug drüber sagen. Wir hatten ja doch schon ein paar Schwerpunkte drauf.
Na, wer hebt die Hand?
Ich dachte, ihr wolltet gerade irgendwas sagen. Wenn wir sagen verschlüsseln, dann heißt es eine Zusatzsoftware benutzen. Eine mögliche ist PGP, das ist die verbreitetste. Viele Leute benutzen heute PGP und da ist auch viel Gutes dran, dass man das benutzt. Das bedeutet, wenn man eine Mail schickt, dass man eben den Text nicht im Klartext schickt, so wie man ihn eingetippt hat, sondern dass man ihn vorher verschlüsselt. Dann wird halt nur irgendwie einen Haufen Müll übertragen, den jemand, der sich das einfach so anguckt, einfach nicht lesen kann. Also er kann ihn natürlich lesen, aber er weiß nicht, was die eigentliche Nachricht darin ist. Und die Gegenseite, derjenige, der es empfängt, kann es deshalb lesen, weil du einen Schüllverschlüssel hast und genauso funktioniert das in die andere Richtung. PGP kann man runterladen, zum Beispiel bei pgpi.com. Dann gibt es das ganze als Privier für verschiedene Betriebssysteme, Windows, Macintosh. Und das bedient sich auch alles ganz brauchbar und arbeitet so mit den normalen Mailprogrammen zusammen. Das heißt, man kann das einfach installieren und benutzen.
Es gibt da noch kleine Probleme mit den Umlauten.
Es gibt jetzt auch eine komplett freie Implementierung, nämlich GNU Privacy Guard, die außerhalb der USA entwickelt wurde und keinerlei patentierter Algorithmen enthält, allerdings los, sicher auf Unix.
Wo ist der eigentlich GNU PG Org? GNU PG Org. Und der läuft schon richtig.
Ist das jetzt von einer 1.0? Nein, eine 1.0 herausgekommen funktioniert auch, ja.
Und was ist daran toller?
Es hält sich im Gegensatz zu OpenPGP an den OpenPGP-Standard.
Und wo hält sich PGP nicht an den OpenPGP-Standard?
So genau hab ich es nicht verfolgt und müsste jemand anders fragen.
Dirk? Ich weiß es auch nicht.
Ich weiß es auch nicht.
Johnny, du hast wieder gesturft.
Ja. Ja, ich hab nämlich gelesen, dass Berlikom in ihrem FAQ schon zwei Megabit-Leitungen anbietet.
Das Problem ist, dass sie denn noch keine Leitungen legen können. Und die Termine liegen irgendwie nicht vor dem ersten 12.
Richtig, sowieso nach Cottbus. So, wo wart ihr gerade?
Ja, ich dachte, wir könnten uns mal ein paar technische Details aufklären.
Wie PGP funktioniert?
Die Unterschiede zwischen genug PG.
Das liegt an verschiedenen Implementierungen der Algorithmen. Danke. Was? So, wir telefonieren jetzt noch sieben Minuten, dann verabschieden wir uns, machen noch ein bisschen Musik, dann gibt's mit dem Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf. Dann müssen wir so ein Jingle produzieren für unsere Telefonnummer hier. Ein Gesungen? Den mag ich am meisten. Hallo? Marianne, sie ist jetzt fett mit der Name auf dem Internet.
Kein Zweifel, das war der einzig denkbare Name.
Ja, du bist dran.
Ja, eben war noch mal Marianne dran.
Ja, genau. Ich bin immer froh, dass ihr Marianne auch kennt, sonst klingt das immer so, als ob ich hier der super unfreundliche Sackleute einfach abwirre.
Ich bin hier nicht.
Marianne auch, aber nicht zu diesem Thema. Ihr sucht doch eine Wohnung in Cottbus. Ich habe einen kostenlosen Internetzugang und zwar hat mich die Telekom irgendwann mal vergessen.
Das ist mir ein Problem.
Meine Frage, die da jetzt hinaus zählt, ich habe meinen Telefonanschluss gekündigt, nachdem ich einen Internetzugang hatte und keine Rechnung mehr. Seit dem 1. April gehen ja die Internetgebühren nicht mehr über die Telefongebühr, sondern separat.
Kann sein, dass sie dir den Service irgendwann abstellen.
Haben sie aber nicht gemacht bisher. Ich habe jetzt seit März oder seit April keine Rechnung bekommen von der Telekom.
Das heißt gar nichts.
Und welche Möglichkeiten haben die denn überhaupt, dass sie überprüfen oder überprüfen die jeden einzelnen Zugang. Ich habe jetzt eine Zugangskennung von einer anderen Nummer benutzt und habe mich hier seit einem halben Jahr wieder eingeloggt. Und ja, ich surfe so schön lang hin und warte irgendwann mal auf die viele Tausend-Mark-Rechnung.
Ja, das könnte durchaus passieren, dass sie kommt. Also es gibt immer wieder so Fälle, wo die Telekom auch mal ein halbes Jahr... Naja, aber dann haben die eigentlich ein Problem. Da muss man bloß erstmal gegen vorgehen.
Hast du denn eine Kündigung von der Telekom?
Nee, ich habe ja den Internetzugang nicht gekündigt. Ich habe nur den Telefonanschluss gekündigt.
Über den Telefonanschluss hast du eine Kündigung?
Aber du benutzt jetzt noch deinen T-Online-Account?
Ich benutze immer noch die Zugangskennung, ja. Ich trau mich gar nicht mehr bei T-Online irgendwie mich einzulocken und zum Beispiel Mitbenutzer. Deswegen hab ich gerade scherzhaft gesagt, ich kann ja glaube ich 99 Mitbenutzer anmelden und würde euch gerne mal meine Zugangskennung geben. Aber ich weiß es nicht, ich muss vielleicht noch eine Weile länger warten. Wenn nach einem Jahr immer noch keine Rechnung gekommen ist, dann ruf ich noch mal an. Ja, nein, wie sehen die Chancen da aus? Irgendwo muss es im Computer ja bei der Telekom gespeichert sein.
Ja, sonst würde es nämlich nicht funktionieren.
Wie überprüfen die das?
Na, die haben da so Programme.
Ja, richtig, also die machen das nicht von Hand. Naja, das wissen wir nicht. Wenn das Programm bis jetzt versagt hat, warum soll es dann plötzlich funktionieren?
Weil es sein kann, dass es nicht ein Programm war, was versagt hat, sondern ein Beamter und ein Beamter fangen an wieder zu funktionieren, im Gegensatz zum Programm.
Da muss es dann halt drüber gehen, über die Lotfals und...
Und ist es jetzt, sag ich mal, wird das Risiko größer, wenn ich jetzt noch bei der Telekom online Geschäfte mache? Also sprich...
Also wir können dir keine umfassende Beratung über die Begehung von Straftaten geben, weil das eigentlich gar nicht so unser Ding ist. Nein. Also es muss ja auf jeden Fall nochmal im Klaren sein, dass das so in dieser Kategorie Leistungserschleichung und so weiter einzubuchen ist. Von daher alles etwas... Oder vielleicht sogar das oder eben auch beides. Ich hab ja von nichts gewusst.
Und deine Nummer steht hier nicht auf dem Display, was ins Internet so was dran war.
Das sehe ich aber die nächste Radiosendung zum Thema Spracherkennung.
Ich werde hier nochmal anhören.
Naja, also wie gesagt, also ich warte ja da auf die große Rechnung irgendwann mal. Und nach zwei Jahren ist das wohl verjährt, aber...
Nach Koltenhaus.
Gut, ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen Abend. Alles klar.
Danke, tschüss. Ja und viel Glück muss man ja dazu sagen. Na los. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio.
Ja hallo, ich bin der Stefan.
Hallo Stefan.
Ich habe mal eine Frage zu den Newsgroups. Habt du mal das Recht, freie Meinungsäußerung und Informationen?
Naja, aber das ist Konzertgeschehen und die Kinderpornografie, du weißt doch.
Außerdem wählst du ja deinen Provider aus, insofern kann man sich vorher erkundigen, was der anbietet. Und das geht ja gar nicht um Einschränkungen der freien Meinungsäußerung, sondern es gibt Provider, die sagen einfach, pass auf, ich brauche hier, weiß ich nicht, ich brauche hier auf meinem System, das richtet sich an Anfänger, ich brauche keine Unix-Diskussionsgruppen oder so. Ist jetzt ein Scheißbeispiel, mir fehlt gar nichts.
Die Microsoft-Newsgroups zum Beispiel haben nicht unbedingt alle. Also als Narvokriste die auch, das ist halt irgendwie Microsoft-Punkt und dann irgendwie sie haben ein Problem mit unserem Programm. Und nicht alle haben diese Newsgroups von kommerziellen Anbietern, aber ich denke, das wird in Zukunft auch alles überall verfügbar sein.
Oder zum Beispiel lokale Newsgroups, also oder, ja, weißte nicht, es gibt einfach...
Gibt es da irgendeinen, irgendeinen, ähm...
Du kannst auch andere Newserver wählen.
Ja, genau, ein Newserver, der alle Gruppen drauf hat.
Na, es gibt einen Server in den USA, der bietet angeblich sämtliche Gruppen. Die sind auch irgendwie redundant auf mehreren Surfern vorhanden. Und wenn du eine Kreditkarte hast, kannst du einfach hingehen und dir einen Akkern kaufen.
Ja, es gibt auch ein paar deutsche Unis, die haben offene Newserver. Ich glaube, Uni Hohenheim. Nicht mehr. Nicht mehr? Auch nicht? Ja, dann weiß ich jetzt gerade keinen Ausflug nach. Du kannst in Alta Vista mal suchen nach free News-Servers.
Oder versuchst bei Deja Com.
Also es gibt welche. Du findest relativ schnell über Alta Vista Seiten, wo Listen mit gültigen freien News-Servern sind.
Mit veralteten Listen, mit nicht mehr gültigen.
Ja, kann ich dir alles nicht garantieren, aber ich hatte da schon Erfolg.
Erstmal viel Spaß dabei.
Soll ich mal einen freien zu finden. Tschüss. Gerade, gerade ich auch online.
Das wird ja wie blöd alles aus.
Das war's schon im Chaosradio. In drei Minuten gibt's den Nightfly mit Martin Petersdorf. Und das war Chaosradio mit Tim, mit Dirk, mit Florian, mit Andreas. Ihr drei wart noch nie hier, ne? Doch, du warst schon mal hier, Doktor.
Ich war noch nicht hier.
Echt nicht?
Ich war mal für eine andere Sendung hier.
Naja, ich werd halt auch internistisch.
Wir haben was anzukündigen. www.ccc.de Ja, www.ccc.de Chaos.es.op.de Am Ende des Jahres werden wir wieder den Chaos-Kommunikationskurs feiern. Mehr dazu irgendwann in Zukunft. Und ansonsten gibt's, glaub ich, nicht wirklich so sehr viel mit, sondern wir haben ja auch noch ein paar.
Nö, viel Spaß am Gerät.
Genau, viel Spaß an der E-Mail.